[Musique]
dutemple et boris les brosses
merci d'être là fini la semaine passée
j'étais décrivait déjà comme le gueut le
plus occupé du québec parce que n'est
pas mon beau frère
[Rires]
pis la semaine passée c'est là qu'on a
vu là soir est encore jeune ouais
pilager fatigués parce que le plus
occupé du québec a dit le moche mais ça
la partie où je change le monde sait ce
n'est qu'au talent mais non mais ça je
pense en fait que vous savez ce que
c'est je pense que dans tmg 26 à jour
obligatoire au 27 ça fait cinq ans que
je pratique mon jeune métier puis enfin
que ce genre de moment je pense que
toutes mes amies sont occupés n'importe
qui je pense que ça fait cinq ans qui
fait sa job et grands dans une espèce de
piques ou bien au début souvent c'est
sûr mais ils m'ont grand chose
plus loin tu peux te calmes et plus à
ossun qu'un espace de pique de parce que
c'était bien travailler ça va bien fait
je pense que tout le monde est occupé
autour de moi c'est juste que mesrine
jobs public
c'est sûr que j'ai l'air occupé pastique
hommes acat injuste en touche et
rechange l'entente de radio j'aille chez
nous je mate et je vois télé puis j'ai
aussi eu sa mi-temps choix comme ça a
l'air presque tout mais si c'est le cas
je travaille dans le cher mais je
faisais 70 75 ans mais ne sait pas plus
puis même si jusqu à ce moment là je te
contre les activistes je pense que oui
je suis occupé mais
j'ai tellement de jeux eu rien que je
veux jamais je suis au lit d'être
fatigué ça m'arrive t mais c'est à moi
ce type i see chose facile de dire non
le x ben tu dis oui à toutes nos l'on
dit non on dit non
ouais mais c'est parce que ce que
n'importe quoi tu sais que la quantité
de demandes grandi puis les je voudrais
faire toutes les levées de fonds voici
fouet toutes les vidéos pour tout le
monde possible
mamane essaient de faire est adressée si
je veux que ma qualité de vie puis que
je reste le fond depuis que je marque
était tout le temps performance est à
personne ok si je vais rester plaisant
plus le fun mais je pense aux monnaies
faut que tu filtre puis moi c'est ma
soeur ma gérante taxer le ricky fils qui
se droguait pas sur la maintenance ac
est en passe mes étés la plupart semaine
un bon être un bon frag
ouais mais ça nous touche autant plus
que ce soit massif quelque chose que moi
j'ai remarqué à propos de toi juste du
temps pour ne pas passer
on a passé beaucoup de temps en temps
mais pas pour durer gros du dropt and
kelly noailles ensemble mais quelque
chose que j'ai remarqué c'est à quel
point qu'elle boit tout anglais généreux
plus dispo sur de flatteurs à san juan à
quel point tu es réellement un gars
généreux c'est quand qu'on était à od à
chaque occasion que tu avais de revenir
à une tache noire puis de parler tu le
faisais et puis tu ne t'es pas obligé de
faire ça comme aujourd'hui n'est pas
obligé d'être ici mais ça a pu tuer
personne n'a reçu ce mardi non non je
n'arrêtais kg il récupère puis effective
mais ça on dirait que ça pour moi ça
fait apprécier encore plus que tu fais à
l'extérieur de juste les communications
interpersonnelles on dirait que de
savoir qui était accessible en
guillemets ça te rend plus humain et
puis je trouve que c'est vraiment
quelque chose que le monde peut-être
savent pas de toi mais que chien a
remercié les gentils ben c'est un je
pense que
la meilleure chose qui est très bonne
chose qui est arrivée pour moi
maintenant dans le métier j'ai un peu
enviable mais symbole mais ses mots au
début ça ça fonctionnait pas super bien
c'est je t'aime je t'aime papa suis un
membre bon mais je pense j'ai toujours
fait c'est vraiment pour les bonnes
raisons c'est à dire que ça me fait
triper c'est fois des jobs puis c'est le
s'est rendue la tlpe c'est ça qui fait
que j'ai pigé un bon instinct qui fait
en sorte que je choisis les choses
vraiment quand j'ai un bon feeling puis
et quand j'aime pas si ça va paraître ça
fonctionnera papier ce que j'aime aussi
l'humain jeunes josi à od à od aussi
c'est que c'était tellement wild comme
contexte encore plus pour vous autres
que pour moi mais moi quand même sorti
de mon quotidien
j'arrivais débats s'animaient déçoit du
monde et le terrain à bali et des gens
que tu connais poppy est la mascotte du
groupe g année c'est comme si on mange
et point commun avec beaucoup de
candidats chaque année c'est quand même
plus en plus vous avez tellement la
maison la maison des gars c'est vraiment
dedans et c'est l'effet chandhok et ça
que les boys et rim plus ça se fait des
joueurs qui n'ont rien à faire en fait
qu'ils s'inventent des jeux et ils ont
l'air de plus ce triplé alors que ma
main je suis le texte était
oui c'est naturel pour moi de le faire
mais c'était aussi une question de mois
j'avais atteint mon premier super passe
la première semaine est bizarre pour
l'animateur parce que vous c puis je
suis pas dans game vaccine normal que je
garde une distance mais vous autres vous
communiquer beaucoup vous apprenez à
connaître la personne moi je débarque
mais la première semaine c'est au
compte-gouttes et parce que c'est
important que les candidats spa entre
qui fait en sorte que le premier super
faut s'asseoir puis je te pose des
questions quand même confrontant tout
comment s'est passée la semaine bleue
faut que le candidat s'ouvre à moi
puis il ne connaît pas le stoppeur tough
puis c'est normal tu es moi je vois un
inconnu s'est un peu dissipée à mener
c'est comme juste de créer un lien puis
un vrai de vrai lien dans ce sens la
télé ça peut devenir facilement fake pub
un groupe c'est normal mais en dessous
de ce cd et rubin qui parle du fait que
je me suis pas j'ai toujours été très
intéressée aussi à l'autre fait que fac
et voilà ouais puisse être cette
connexion la plus ça allait me plus ça
allait plus à mieux meyers est devenu ti
j'ai eu le feeling là quand je t'ai vu
monter les marches 6 puis pendant quatre
mois de ma vie quand je voyais déjà
monté les marches c'est quelque chose de
l'fun qui se passe chaque fois infecte
encore encore mon ma réponse c'est ça ma
réponse encore à devoir toi c'est
comment
mais c'est sociale annonce c'est spécial
parce que tous les candidats et
candidates avec qui j'ai partagé au
débat lits ont été tout le monde est
revenue petit monde a eu sa vie qui a
vraiment le vent d'un voile qu'on est
super occupée puis tout le monde s'est
bien placé mais à chaque fois que je
croise un candidat ou une candidate
je me sens vraiment comme c'est ce qui
est arrivé comme quand un voyage qui te
croiser quelqu'un en voyage des
véhicules courte space c'est peut être
plutôt m shon quand tu reviens mais à
chaque fois tu revois cette personne là
il ya une espèce de connexion naturel
qu'il faudrait aller on a chéri de quoi
être vraiment spécial puis d'unique puis
ça mais ça ça se défait potes c'est ça
que j'ai vraiment ce feeling et jours
plus tard âgé des petits fils a tout
d'abord dit oui à ça ça a changé ta vie
complètement
ouais mais comme comme ph
vraiment ça cela d'une manière
différente mais très similaires d'un
mois au départ j'ai dit non la ville fut
jugé l'offre
j'y repensais cette semaine passée la
vie va tellement ça fait un an
ça fait un an jour pour jour il ya
quelque chose qui s'en venait pis aller
ça allait tout changer ça n'a aucun bon
sens comment la vie va vite quitté les
faux sites et le sait le feeling la
rentrée le non sens où ces émeutes ont
ils dit il il ya des check-point dans
ton année ou tekken qui atteint 6,2
petit mouton justement raconté notion
d'acte cela rend triste un gros moment
d'acheter ou l'année passée je radio
cette année le mot sioniste cod ça fait
comme ça j'en reparle le jeu des appels
quand je me souhaite offrir à double on
dirait que c'est hier - piste et mon
dieu que ma vie était autre chose puis
en même temps il rien que changé si ce
qui se passe ici c'est que ça change
mais c'est paraît-il mais quand je me
suis triste double
moi je pensais que je devenais
chroniqueur pour aude et plus en direct
qui est l'émission à musiqueplus qui
joue à préaux des in the rain un meeting
géant mercredi matin à 10 ans momo sarr
médecin puis jusqu'au boss d'un meeting
avec les gens qui font des plus ce qui
est des humoristes que je connais que je
post pressé le meeting est à 10 heures
me lève à 9h45 et je mets 10 août à
billets sans supplément d'âme et manière
puisque ton monte et que j'arrive le je
rentre à 10 eur puis à 2 et puis
j'arrive à la fédération tu viens
pourquoi moi dans ma tête comme c'est
sûr que quelqu'un qui est arrivé avant -
c'est un chemin des pelouses mais comme
tu es rencontres et qui les énoncent
poussière puis à ce moment là j'ai
aucune des six qui sommes là aujourd'hui
et c'était le directeur de la
programmation de v à ce moment là et je
maman et comme son assistant bien
cherché aujourd'hui j'ai dit que plus ça
brasse en meeting à ce moment là j'ai
aucune des qui autour de la table à ce
moment là aujourd'hui je sais dire et à
la programmation
la productrice de rodez la productrice
au contenu comme c'est tout du monde que
mais il disait s'être pige comprend
poser c'est si les puits comprend pas
kosice
quand ça jasait service total je
mangeais des chaux de fonds puis
l'animation
moi je pense qu'ils pensent de plus
chiant je peux pas être là
direct à quatre semaines j'ai des choses
n'ont cessé son talent de haut des
animaux dit que je participe au g20 et
non comme je te revoilà pouces qui
mobiliserait et le 18 marie viala post
rhissa mais julie snyder le téléphone b
comme vers la belgique où tu vas des
secrets mais ça se passe à bali toi ta
vie l'autre le gicam homme un coup de
chapeau de bon sens je pense a pris deux
semaines prendre mon souffle
puis ça a été tellement un moment oui
mais dans ma vie parce que ce coup j'ai
refusé deux jours après julie me
rappelle et je me sens qu'on dit non
c'est pas rencontré pleins et puis on va
quand même travailler ensemble sur des
plus jeunes le pot de fer perds ton
temps
maintenant je prends pas mon temps je
veux juste qu'on se rend compte qu'ils
vendent un gros gros aussi trois heures
et demie avec julie ma soeur puis gelé
pour vraiment bonne mais assez a fait
ses devoirs
c'est cela fasse et que c'est pas juste
un requin qui rentrent dedans c'est à
l'été lire mes textes sur bagnols pour
l'apparat zone non c'est cela le fait
ses recherches il ce soit en leur
sautant du meeting ce soir le j'anime à
saint-lazare d'antenne sont ritmo être
débarqué à saint nazaire ce sont le
voulez voir le show ils peuvent pour
faire des pressions pour me voir
c'est comme ça que ça a été tu étais
vraiment un moment oui depuis tu vois
que ce suivi s'est en fait tu prends le
temps tel ou tel week-end pour y penser
puis ce week end là j'allais pas bien le
choc et qui me faire la job
j'avais pas quoi faire je n'avais pas de
ce que les autres d'humoristes allez
penser pas le public paul le monde la
télé parce que je pense que tout le
monde le public un grand respect pour
l'animation télé puis le monde à télé au
site et y voit crime c'est un gros show
puis c'est parfait les humoristes on est
très cynique comme green fait que
j'étais comme j'avais un peu peur de ce
qu'ils pensent et puis remanié le lundi
matin j'étais supposé avoir donné ma
réponse je vais pas donner encore je
vois dean est mon meilleur ami et je
suis dévastée d'une seconde alors de
rechange aux manèges comme eh oui oui
mais oui mais oui c'est écrit ça va être
la sienne après n'ont pas besoin de ça
va bien ma vie
et je suis parti du dîner puis mon match
mais ce pas après je t'assure tu dis non
je m'en allais schéma serge arrêt chez
ma soeur et je vois juste boudé j'ai
juste été boudés chez jours par là même
projeté juste comme désagréable
il partit d'être le puits le réussit à
mai à midi peu après comme je t'assure
que refuser à la plume paradis il vous
dit
et ce soir les animaux au joker avant
soirée du mot que j'animais depuis trois
ans et le lundi soir sur scène allait
bien puis ce téléphone puis j'ai regardé
la corde
je pense pas que ces gens-là vont me
détester
si j'aï si janet monde et dans ma peau
je pense que je peux être plus qu'une
chose dans la vie je pense que ces gens
le savent qui je suis où du moins il
semble comprendre qui je suis dit ça va
pas changer puis ultime en ci il se base
juste sur leur perception de ce qu'est
od pour me juger
ultima j'ai vu panama satisfait car il
ya exact que j'ai faite fin quittons le
fai puissent y avait des amis qui est un
humoriste suisse dans ma vie celle qui
était l'homme se shoote seppi après son
geste puis je fais un peu contrarié com
qu'est-ce qui est ses fils comme je me
souhaite offrir l'animation d'une grosse
télé réalité chez pac enfin il fait
occupation double c'est gigantesque
mais tu fais on s'en fout il ya juste
quand je vous ai tous en crise j'ai fait
13 ans puis le lendemain matin j'ai
appelé que j'accepte et puis je suis
vraiment vraiment vraiment rester la
même façon pour la deuxième saison de
lost et gauche jouent à la deuxième
saison si j'ai dit et je pense que ce
qui a été dur là parce que puis on l'a
vécu vraiment différemment mais je pense
que il ya une part ou c'est similaire ou
le débuté sur une bulle c'est vraiment
vraiment mal
tu comprends pas ce qui est en train de
vivre c'est vraiment unique comme show
il rien qui sa progéniture et ont mené
le teint faits sont infirmes année c'est
normal tout le monde est fatigué tout le
monde est hérité c'est dur sur le moral
c'est dur sur les émotions encore plus
pour eux que pour nous nous c'est
différent parce que puis je dis nous
c'est vraiment plus l'équipe c'est
vraiment dans le jeu est une espèce de
cinq six personnes vraiment voir le
corps qui va faire avec vie plm ainsi la
pression des codes des courts depuis
subi fait le mot ni un espèce de petit
hostilités qui s'installe puis à fin à
bali je pense que tout le monde plein
son casse et la mère s'occupe hervé si
le voyage final moi je suis arrivé à
singapour et je me suis même j'ai certes
cyclique est parfaite comme on dit on a
retrouvé deux je suis redevenu les juges
sur devenu épais puis déranger tout le
monde plus juste le fun ça tellement
fait du bien pour moi c'est un capot le
dernier super sa peau - j'y repense
encore comme étant un des moments
vraiment forts de la saison il sait pas
cette fois autour de cette table il y
avait un énorme respect les uns envers
les autres et qui sait manette cette
conversation le ca a été moins un gros
moment pour moi c'est super le buste et
télévisés mais je trouve ça vraiment
humain comme conversation et il est
survenue au québec est là et c'est là
aussi je savais aussi à faire mal et
enfin faut que faut que je revienne au
québec pour me faire une tête là-dessus
faux j'ai fini de faire tout ce pot
vraiment comprendre c'est quoi quand je
suis revenue
mais la chute a l'air tout le monde en
parle j'ai eu une très grosse entrevue
dans la presse
j'ai vu comment qu'on me recevait puis
je m'attendais pas à ce genre d'accueil
lee qui a été très généreux et très le
fun
puis j'ai fait qu'ils aient atteint
ainsi coup le titre on a bien fait sur
piste alphone que j'ai bien fait de le
faire
les gens ont vu que c'est dans vie à
l'art du divertissement ça existe la
diversité fait que manet
le lendemain mon passage à tout moment
par le lundi matin j'avais des entrevues
radio fin je me suis vu comme 50 du
matin et puis et là je chanterai
déjeuner avec l'attaché de presse
charles puis il y en avoir
et puis ne venge pas vraiment montré
[Musique]
massa m'appelle loin au dernier puis
vers catane est montée et je savais pas
avant d'être revenu non j'adore on est à
cinq six jours de la finale
ok et je suis bon il ya une partie de
moi qui souhaitais que ça revienne pour
pouvoir prendre des gardes étaient six
jeux qui m'ont insulté et l'a finalement
ça le lendemain je dînais avec encore
une fois essayer encore une fois c'est
un espèce de moments où tu as les gens
ma vie est tellement changé entre la
danse fois j'ai dîné que vous anticipez
aujourd'hui fit les cheveux puis moi je
tape pas convaincu mais en même temps
mes craintes par rapport à cela il y
existait plus dans le sentiment crainte
à od pas stade est associé à occupation
double x and with ma carrière et ça pas
du tout été le cas au contraire s'est
faite là c'était plus eu la crainte le
steak sommes ok tu en sais quoi
les craintes étaient reliés vraiment
travail il ya des choses que j'ai pas
aimé la bo puis on certains cds petit
héritage d'un groupe les noirs de jeu me
fait payer pour aller à bali pilon en
grèce je suis vraiment chanceux il ya
des fous est souvent déjà ça ça n'a pas
été évident à gérer tout seul comme je
payais pour a la balle il ya pire t il
ya vraiment pire que ce que fait que la
manne et je me suis assise puis j'ai
fait à cat 1
c'est quoi les conditions qui ferait que
je leur ferais je vais enfin ceux qui
ont accepté des jo la première année
j'ai accepté beaucoup pour l'expo jeu
cette année c'est vraiment pour le
plaisir vraiment pour le plaisir parce
que l'équipe est extraordinaire chez les
fondeurs faire quelque chose que tu as
déjà fait fac les d'arriver plus frais à
tanger si c'est quoi l'année passée ça
m'a pris en trois semaines
thomas catchy c'était comme mon travail
c'était quoi ma place par rapport aux
candidats puis aller qui épie est fait
je suis toujours un peu comme un jeu
petit comme je le fais que tyler et je
sais où je m'en vois je sais c'est quoi
je suis vraiment excité c'est factuel ça
a été c'est une grosse décision mais une
fois qu à été prêché comme le goupillon
porte quoi puisque l'émission
parce que la mission est là - mais ce
que l'approché la main vous essayez
toujours de différent au niveau des
candidats au niveau de votre semaine
c'est ce qu'ils espèrent cette année
j'ai moins impliqué dans le préau des
l'année passée je vous accueillir la
deuxième journée d'audition
j'aimais ça parce que le lait il m'a pas
demandé mon hypothèse commenté à trouver
qui disent choisir est cette année j'ai
été jeté en spectacle beaucoup fait que
jeter moins le je pense que le d'etzella
n'est pas assez visiblement produits
proposés fait une proposition d'
occupation double qui était vraiment
différent de d'habitude
de par le choix des candidats de par mon
choix - veste et sa queue on continue
dans cette direction latifa que je pense
que il ya un côté ça reste et ça on vend
du révolté si on en voit des êtres
humains vraiment naissent dans des
endroits paradisiaques et il restera pas
de public mais la base c'est vraiment de
choisir des êtres humains coloré bill
fuente les choses c'est les candidats
c'est pas moins six fois que je pense
que la décision elle la vision est la
même on continue dans cette direction là
où ça change c'est toujours faut brosser
à supporter parce que c'est rendu la
douzième saison fin évidemment le public
connaît la game
mais les candidats aussi sacs faut
toujours constamment surprendre tout le
monde s'est fait que fait quoi puis à
quel point parce que j'en viens quand il
disait que les dernières semaines avant
de partir vers 5 heures postes les plus
difficiles mais je rappelle on a eu des
moments où est-ce qu'ils étaient
clairement on était tous le mont héry
tétouan inclusive puis à quel point tu
étais investi dans dans le jeu si on
veut est-ce que tu sentais que je vous
recommande
est-ce que tu sentais que tu avais un
impact dans le travers le jeu est ce que
tu sentais ce qu'ils avaient des choses
quitte irritait par rapport aux
candidats qui avaient des choses que tu
es tu puis je te demande pas donner des
exemples spécifiques je sais ce que c
est ce que tu te sens tu inverse
si dans d'autres encore détaché rendu là
quand c'est devenu plus moi je pense que
je me suis protégé la bonne enfant je
voulais pas de préférer ce qui est dur
en partance et sur les c'est normal
c'est d'en avoir exposé chaque mois
souvent j'essaie être pas trop vous
écoutez pour que ma vision nous autres
demain les condensations j'avais pauvres
et que vous la ou moins souvent été
hérités c'est qu'un moi je suis le
messager et et puis c'est un gros jeu
que pas de règle va cloud et fois c'est
off puis le haut moi des fois je suis
probablement trop détaché et c'est
correct parce que je peux pas être trop
investi comme animateur
c'est quand qu'on arrive avec des
touristes qui dérange des candidats marc
d'ascom cessa games et blanc dans six
mois mais même quand tu joues au quai
lors je me fais chier
il est un fait que c'est un peu c'est la
seule place où des fois puis je pense
que là où c'est difficile aussi je pense
que le ou même vous autres votre manning
a peut-être changé c'est quand vous ai
fait visiter la maison dangereuse que tu
vois la grosseur de la régie perter
guertin le stum c'est impressionnant un
mur avec 40 kame il ya du monde les
archivistes place nos constatations un
journée longue ça que je pense que le
aussi vous autres c'est normal parce qu
on vous garde une place où on ne la
jugent urgent si je danse puis je tends
fleury c'est sûr qu'on a la dette chez
les personnes qui chelsea puis je suis
de loin la personne qui le plus de sacs
seller je pense qu'il ya un décalage
entre puis c'est plus sévère puis je
vous l'avais dit cette fois c'est
vraiment plus pour les garçons pelé
caméraman plus réactif
les archivistes sont comme à longueur de
journée tellement investie puisqu'elle
tellement pour la zone mais tellement le
temps une personne faisant vous ayez de
la peine du fait que c'est là où je
pensais à un décalage que vous étiez pas
conscients qu'ils avaient ça et c'est
normal parce que vous le voyez passer
fax et là oh moi des fois je me sentais
un peu entre deux de faire j'ai beaucoup
d'empathie pour vous autres passez moi
je vous vois jalonnement aucune empathie
pour eux aussi parce que le g voix
j'ai juste envie tout le monde comprenne
que tout le monde semble justement
fonctionne fax et là au moins je me
sentis investis mais vraiment dans
l'espèce de bien être de tout le monde
c'est plus que la game cela games et
plates vous autres vous pouvez vraiment
fort quand quelqu'un est éliminé ça
change ton quotidien
moi je propose est dévasté je trouve ça
plate mais moins à la seconde qui
accueille sortie je suis plus proche des
jeux de cette personne s'est fait que
l'accession puis effectivement si c'est
tellement city c'est tellement une
petite affaire en rétrospective qui
mettons les deux dernières semaines
avant qu'on voit l'autre côté bois c'est
quand tu es dedans c'est un cauchemar
c'est un tourbillon sans enfant est pris
aussitôt que ok la décision et fait les
trois finalistes les droits qu'au final
ils sont là on traverse dans maison la
preuve c'est qu'un pas qui nous entoure
le pire du monde qui était le puits
c'est plate à des concentrations que des
gens qui te parler d accès là c'est
quand qu'ils aient le droit par la prod
qui avait juste parlé à gamme mettons le
système celle avec qui j'ai parlé puis
c'est quand qu'ils ont par là le secteur
parce que c'est vraiment une grosse [ __ ]
à karachi staff arlon pis pour le type
cc qui étoffent c'est que les gens qui
font od depuis longtemps il ya des gens
dans lesquels les preuves qui sont là
depuis super longtemps pis ils
connaissent le shopi savent ce qui quoi
faire et quoi faire pour protéger les
candidats protéger tout le monde sait
aussi de justesse par la peine d'être
emboutie fac et des fois si woods à
comprendre mais si ce qui étoffent ces
cas là si vous avez vécu la même chose
tout à fait de la tour de la patente
pour te faire une tête au tour de ceux
ayant acquis
c'est normal que quand tu es au milieu
de toutes ces intenses le c'est normal
puis merde moi le premier dans ce
contexte l'ue je serai là pure personne
je deviendrai le tlm a drama queen le
ciel enfin
mais c'est fait c'est ce que j'aime ce
rôle d'animateur c'est pour ça que je le
vaux bien comme la mascotte youppi mois
à auditer faut que tout le monde soit
content de me voir tout le temps puis
que les gens ont confiance en moi pour
s'ouvrir à moi puisque c'est un espèce
de gaulle
super le fun puis vraiment unique qui
est pas celui de lee d'attaqué à qui tu
parles beaucoup évidemment mais au moins
j'ai un espèce de rôle
cachez ce pays ne veut cacher mais c'est
vraiment une affaire d'entente qui fait
en sorte que faut que tout le monde soit
content de me voir tout le temps vie
j'aime bien sûr parce que c'était dans
les situations où est-ce que tout
justement il porte parole des décisions
prises par la prod suu kyi
tout avoir une décision avec laquelle tu
paies que total a pas pris longtemps
qu'ils existent avait participé à la
décision mais ton parti tu mets ton en
amont pour cent en ce moment ce qui va
se passer cette saison je sais pas je
t'ai pas le rendu est la bonne
ils vont souhaiter je vois est là d'un
conversation c'est sûr c'est moi que ça
va faire l'annoncé fait que je suis le
jeu des fois il ya des conversations
qu'est ce qu'on fait je peux participer
mais je trouve que la puissance d'une
bonne équipe de télé c'est de faire
confiance comme équipe de foot faire
confiance aux rôles de chacun avec moi
mon rôle c'est d'être un bon message
estime d'être à l'écouté des candidats
d'état les coûts de la prod puis de bien
partager le message parce que je tout le
temps en train de donner des tenthrèdes
explique un jour un jeu non-stop fait
que pierre monnet moi ça me prit un
trois semaines quatre chez son frère tom
hall 1 mon rôle à moi c'était un bon
communicateur
c'est ça mon travail à moi concentre là
dessus qu'ils soient le plus rire
possibles soit le plus humain possible
plus clair soit sa fac je trouve que la
puissance n'est que de la télé c'est
justement des photos comme pourquoi ils
ont tendance à plat tous parce qu'il
mène le cameraman qui fait c'est qu'ils
filment meilleur goût qui est là pour
qu'un contourne politiciens la came
c'est sa job pour que le caméraman soit
toujours détail ne manquait cinq mois
c'est là où je fais mais l'équipe de
prod leur job le il ça fait des mois
tout ce qu'ils font c'est pense à ce
qu'on va faire la difficulté c'est
grandiose sixième septième termine
huitième semaine faut encore que je
passe de quoi c'est ce qui est dur si
sagan qui se referme année moi c'est là
où je fais bénédiction monarchie comme
as tu sais quoi fouetter un peu sadiques
c'est trop fort mais faut être un peu
comme il faut pas oublier que le but
c'est de faire un show télé oui c'est là
où c'est off est selon moi je pourrais
pas prendre les bonnes décisions dans ce
cas là parce que moi j'ai eu à l'aide
gaudin des affaires piratés dur parce
que mon chien est justement je produis
mon choix même humoristes patentés
décision tout seul sur scène c'est là où
j'ai fait a été l'animateur de signer un
contrat à nîmes puis je aller au lit
nadal je vois et je vais faire le mieux
que je peux puis il fait vraiment le lot
de tout ça autour de moi puis j'ai juste
comme livres et essayer de livrer la
marchandise
il y avait l'histoire que tu racontes et
tu me l'avais racontant mois ou à une
coupe de deux candidats je me rappelle
plus mais je pense que c'est intéressant
quand même quand tu es raconte comment
sentait quand était venu annoncer le
deuxième tapis rouge mais parce que se
tient on parlait obtus de la question
c'est est-ce que des fois il ya des
décisions mais cette histoire-là de de
stress parce que c'est ça veut pas je me
rappelle quand qui m'ont expliqué à cela
la décision du deuxième tapis se faisait
longtemps que tu es pressé je me
souviens avant que je connaisse les
candidats ceux qui me disent ah et comme
on y voit un twist deuxième tapis rouge
et des nouvelles filles qui arrivent
plus et je me rappelle lâcheté gicam
non 10 et là la journée arrêté puis
cette fois l'un c'est très différent
allait annoncer dans la maison des gars
calais annoncée la maison des filles
surtout cette nouvelle
et là moi je veux rencontrer les filles
du deuxième tapis avant rapide ou un
puissant foule excitée puis ça rappelle
un oui c'est vrai ce texte est tout seul
si nous ramenons légèreté en main qu'à
dispose de coiffes cod vente à bas les
vies toute la nouveauté avec la chanson
finie
j'arrive pileux une fois l oreillette et
j'ai toujours mon oreillette qui me
parlait classe bien
la régie se plaît tout le monde et comme
tout on était derrière moi genre c'est à
vos badges et on est de la régie et age
i'm back to était d'origine turque est
en vacances il fait le tout le monde
était là
ces denrées jpy et le juste dans mon
oreille je suis dehors des maisons des
gueux ses pieds c'est juste gilles la
réalisation j on est avec toi tu peux y
aller type d'ordre et le stand rien
vas-y quand il veut et le ont montré des
images de corps on montrait d'été au
départ c'est une gaffe on est entrain
ondes tout le québec a vu le tapis rouge
voulu voir des images tapis rouge women
certainement curieux c'est que ces
boules tapis rouge voit des images
henry a c'est vrai et l enfant au
téléphone ça finit hélas molay littry
pleut pendant tapis rouge et moi plus ça
avance plus je capote et je veux qu est
ce qu a monté ma phrase je veux pas je
peux mais je peux pas me tromper
ça finit les grèves contre oui bon il ya
une affaire que vous savez pas tout le
québec est au courant sauf vous regardez
ce qui s'est passé après vous aviez
quitté le tapis rouge c est le pass
l'extrait où j'explique le deuxième
tapis rouge des faits ici et là les
gamines lpx lève comme fo kenja réunir
now furtif saddam de viella d'amour tout
le monde capote ph mais les gosses cette
règle mais le jeu ne fait pas le ménage
à d'une averse côté des fils ebrue le
sais tu n'y es mesures comme un spam
stressé dit quand j'y repense mais est
que plus le tapis rouge avant ces pelés
fils cheikh baye times les fils est
chaque boucle les goehry telefe siam
c'est comme il fut primé sur sont là
dessus on vomit sociales sont vraiment
très critique envers elle légitime
comme dit savent même pas ce qui s'en
vient c'est hélas mon coeur bat est
tellement fort j'avais l'impression que
mon chemin chemise levée c'était fou
comment mon coeur bat fort et encore une
fois je me regardais dans le cam de la
prod c'est pendant que ça a joué
comme j'étais juste dire qu'on est avec
toi terminal et le et il ya un moment où
je me suis dit je peux être en danger
physiquement et les choses ça roule et
le les faits jusqu'à me la fasse le
deuil de ses droits par la gauche c'est
que quand ça s'appelle michael c
puis c'est là où ma tante et épicé c'est
qu'il bouche trou de rodez c'est que
c'est vraiment un chien mais tout le
monde sait qui libre d'accès il ya des
filles qui paniquent et puis d'autres
métiers alexandra c'est maintenant
l'heure de jeu comme on était en
occupation double et puis si ça fait pas
cela games puis en amont les faits des
camions on va les faire chier quand vous
rentrez puis le premier soir que sera
très difficile comme il est trop ce
matin puis on prend de champagne qui
s'approprie tati cela paraisse 29
magnétique on est mélangé les chambres
et ça a été mais ce genre de moments où
j'ai fait comme ati une coupe de petit
twist comme ça que moi je peux pas me
tromper
qui va comme sonné c'était messi laissé
ni un jeu quand même un tailleur mettons
cette moment dans saison comme il le
faut vraiment c'est comme quand
j'annonce un voyage le bus et peut se
tromper mais si ça fait trente secondes
que chez que le lac s'appelle croit
dabba doo les gens sachent que je me
trompe c'est pas grave on va leur
prendre plus correct mais ce genre de
tombola oui
mais
ces facs ce genre d'épreuve est moins
stressant mais mais là cette année je me
sens beaucoup plus équipés pour nana qui
est sûr de tout cela parce que je suis
comme je suis plus confiant lundi
je pense que peut-être aussi le fait que
je veux je doutais pas à la dépense en
le disant mais je pense que le fait que
cette année j'assume plus ce rôle de fer
droit des doublés débloquer dans le jeu
je sais c'est que je suis jointe cette
tête de l'ancienne bourse avec la star
pour six mois je veux l'assumer plus par
cette année sera peut être moins à les
coteaux plus méchant juste facom puis je
pense l'avantagé 6 externe et peut-être
des candidats vont plus savoir chips
comme haïti en excuser mais oui c'est la
grande question
les gens savent quand même pas dans quoi
il s'embarquait et quel point attendre
rien faire non puis oui c'est là aussi
des fois aussi battisti creed en contre
mais si jamais comme le vit c'est la
même chose que moi c'est yorbeau
t'expliquer il faut vraiment que tu
passes au travers pour comprendre ces
puis je pense que les candides élevé
vraiment différemment puis ce qui est
dur c'est que fort peu les laisser seuls
qui sont pas tous se sont jamais tout
seul ces puits sont libres de faire ce
qu'ils veulent c'est ça la france mais
c'est il ya une espèce aussi de partis
ou c'est ce qui est sûr le site d'al
contexte ils n'ont pas l'air mais les
candidats font partie de l'équipe de
prod comme dans ça c'est comme mais on
fait un show vraiment tout le monde
ensemble puis si vous tout le monde
travaille à ce que vous chantiez tpiy je
pense que tu es ce que tu es ce que tu
pensais vraiment que faire road et
amènerait ici aujourd'hui
en rétrospective on savait que ça allait
avec les médias sociaux on savait que ça
allait lever plus que les autres années
la lah préau des mois ces émeutes on a
parlé les gueules cassées rencontre la
première fois on savait on savait qu
est-ce qui s'emmenait parce que juste
d'avoir un compte instagram saga
maintenant la grosse plateforme
on savait qu'en sortant on n'allait pas
rapidement tombé dans l'oubli elle
le du public tu es dans les autres
années si tu te rendais pas en finale le
monde
oubliez vite pas mal et puis le fait que
l'on savait que ça allait se passer de
cette ampleur là jamais de la vie fils
et je regarde je regarde à l'année
explique comment ces affaires sont
partis en fout après od quelqu'un qui
serait partie la première semaine
dans n'importe quel autre édition jamais
ce serait ici puis même moi de sortir de
là avec un thé en 2018 un compte à 120
mille abonnés instagram c'est même au
delà de tir mais c'est ça que je trouve
aussi que c'est que tu veux toi
sincèrement des sorties de terre en
amour avec une belle opportunité devant
et puis c'est là où je trouve aussi des
fois ci c'est mutuellement de la
reconnaissance des deux bords je pense
que tout le monde gagne daudet
reconnaissant pour ce que vous avez fait
cette année parce que le show c'est vous
autres
je pense que c'est ce qu'ils font n'est
qu'en disait c'est que tous les
candidats sans de reconnaissance enfin
merci de l'opportunité de cette fois ça
a pris un certain temps par exemple - ce
soir que j'imagine que c'est peut-être
la nature la déformation professionnelle
compétiteur c'est normal c'est la
romance et que tu vas gagner dans
situation que j'étais petit on écouter
les émissions avec si on était à
tremblant on écoute et émission avec du
monde ces quatre personnes qui n'étaient
pas ensemble
la personne qui était était fake dans ma
situation quand s'est passée que c'est
quoi l'intérêt du public quand il s'est
passé quoi tecla le qu'est ce que le
monde pense de toi
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que je on
s'attendait à gagner mais pas
nécessairement à cause de ça que ça m'a
pris du temps note juste
juste parce que je sais pas je suis pas
habitué à contrôler qu'est ce qui est
montré de moins puis puis se soucient
pas su me trompe mais yens participe
aussi de ses matons moi le pire tournage
j'ai trouvé pour moi pour ma part ça a
était l'heure de vérité qui est le
lendemain de la finale la finale pour
moi pis pour toi ça soit on tue son mât
vécue très différemment de moi moi la
finale ça a été pas mal le moment le
plus stressant de ma jeune vie
professionnelle dans direct pendant dix
minutes c'est pire est en direct dix
minutes qu une note un peu comme guedj
et honte en 10 minutes et dix minutes on
peut pas bosser avec je tombe s'il y
avait tellement d'éléments il fait froid
t d'or des gens nerveux des familles qui
monte des figues confites cipi sur le
site et comment staff 10 bonnes affaires
du groupe et le pointe très loin je vois
rien je vois pas le temps j'ai ça a
vraiment été un moment que je pensais
pas me rendre au travail j'ai rarement
été aussi nerveux avant quelque chose
j'étais insupportable avant d'entrer en
nombre vraiment vraiment puis en sortant
enfin comme j'ai un peu craqué pourquoi
j'ai passé au travers et ça a c'est fini
dans ma tête c'était ce moment là
j'étais comme c'était tellement positif
c'était tellement positif je trouve
c'est l'accomplissement d'une grosse
montagne qu'on pensait pas vraiment
passé au travers le regard depuis un
port grande consult et le lendemain on
est allé petty ce là la vérité puisque
je puisse normal comme on a besoin de ce
show là je pense qu'il ya des choses qui
ont besoin d'être dites moi m'a le plus
pour vous autres que pour les autres ce
kit offre de ce tournage le sait que les
candidats sont pas toutes la même place
dans leur deuil mais échoue dans sa
structure n'est pas ma place par rapport
à leur aventure qu'on dirait qu'il y en
a d'autres et non pas par est exact mais
je sais qu'il y en a qui ont fait qu'ils
ont vécu une vie après ou des jeux sont
déjà rendus ailleurs ils savent y ont eu
la réponse du public ils savent que à
mangane attend le public et compte un
peu pour ce que tu en as fait dans
l'aventuré le public est super il te du
monde trèbes software puis peut-être
plus que la cipd vous autres vous veniez
débarquer vous venez d'apprendre que
vous avez perdu
vous n'avez pas encore votre téléphone
vous êtes mix feeling que j'ai fait
mais c'est normal d'avoir comme un petit
mois maintenant au moins un mois pour
absorber cette facon matin c'est vrai
ouais peut-être que monétairement sur le
coup c'est intéressant de gagner mais
dans le contexte dans lequel on
aujourd'hui que vos comptes et 56e je
pense qu'ils n'ont vraiment pas d'épicés
ce que j'ai trouvé le fond des candidats
des balises et que vous avez parce que
ce qu'on entend encore beaucoup parler
vous faites quelque chose et ne
serait-ce que lp continent avant sont
jim qui est rendue porte parole pour des
trucs qui ont rapport avec lui pesait
c'est super bon il ya quelque chose
était à l'anis noémie toit puis jesse
fac c'est ce qui est le fun je trouve ce
que vous en avez fait quelque chose ses
factures
c'est super positif t moi je me rappelle
aux à l'heure de vérité c'est comme tu
dis on n'avait pas vu les on n'avait pas
vu de contact avec internet rien on
n'avait pas vu les mines ce qui elle
peut amener il fait un commentaire puis
a dit moi je n'en avais pas pour être le
roi comme le roi ph plus j'ai fait au
bois
il a fait référence au roi ph c'est moi
qui était quelque chose qui on écoute
les émissions le sketch il c'était loin
le nom matt stone c'est affaire de rien
puis le lp qui fait mention le che a
manqué quelque chose de plus gros qui
s'il est mal faite et c'est là aussi où
c'est quand même tous été fouillés toi
quand tu es revenue tout surmonté aller
voir les commentaires fait me déranger
c'est
comment mes parents ont vécu six mois
parce que tu es un pour un parent même
si c'est un commentaire positif comme en
négatif c'est lui qui t'empêche de
dormir la nuit
effectivement mort est obligé de partir
en vacances la semaine après que je me
dise arrête de regarder sa chef pas moi
j'ai fait le retour pitié ma carapace
est assez pâle ce fait que ça m'a pas
dérangé d'un club toute façon on me
reprochait de trop bien m'exprimer
effectif c'est quand même c'est pas ces
musiques mon meilleur ami tao des jeux
tu es vraiment aux difficultés immenses
et sur tout ce que je pouvais écouter
très utile serait pas nos experts
possible mais mode et la nuit
sérieusement je pense cette année c'est
quelque chose qu'on a quand même réussi
à faire c'est que on a vraiment qui je
pense que puis quand je dis on c'est
inclus comme littéralement tout le monde
qui travaille sur rodez je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé mais une magie qui
opérait qui fait en sorte que oui tant
marque évidemment parce que tu qu'un spa
chemin du monde qui me disent ah j'avais
jamais écouté sa vista ne sais pas
pourquoi je l'écoutais ouvrait se
chicaner cote 1 défaite
ouais mais tu veux vraiment pas
embarquer le sétois loin parce que cette
année contre 1 théo klein est vraiment
des quads addictif dans là dedans je
passais quoi mais c'était poignée à coup
sûr mais bref qu'un taux intervenue
parce que tu es revenue un peu plus un
peu plus tôt le 23 novembre les
techniques d'entrevue plus moi
j'écoutais tout pour avoir des petites
infos des petits enfants que je pouvais
parce qu'ils sont plus d'amateurs de
radio d'état demande c'est qu'il est
boys qui tu t'entends le mieux ouais
blitz by montant mais quel pc andré
kadhafi tu as fait ta baraque mais c'est
ce qui était facile c'est des questions
chez comme c'est dur de nommer parce que
sincèrement je m'entendais bien clio cup
et en fait partie mais je me rappelle
pas n'a pas la bonhomie
parce que c'est c'est sait rien contre
les fils sincèrement mais on m'a
tellement dit au début les faits vont
triper sur j'aime tellement les
commentaires des que une fillette
éliminé l'entrevue dans voiture il
suffisait que je dise un compliment la
quantité de rumeurs que une maison sur
moi est littéralement toutes les
candidates que naturellement je me
gardais plus une distance et khlifi
qu'avec les gars donc les boys je
rentrais dans ma maison que j'allais
chez les couples puissent entrer une
coupe de foisonnement et c'est cet ifa
qui était à coire et je pense que c'est
normal que les gueux qui partent dans
les premières semaines ont soit un peu
moins proche on les a moins vu métier je
descendrai que ph
adamo puis elle paie ça a été quand même
les gars avec qui j'ai passé en guinée
le plus de temps non mais c'est pas ce
weed charismatique à rémy et moins et
moins il y parle - fa qui m'est fait que
voilà le team et je me suis vraiment
bien entendu avec les garçons l'année
passée c'était vraiment le fun
un coup c'est cool moi quelque chose que
je voulais je voulais parler
l'écart avec horreur que tu faisais moi
j'ai eu beaucoup d'entrevues dans ma vie
pour la natation principalement puis
pour tuer ma carrière d'athlète et
étudiants puis téteux des talents de
d'entrevue heures quand même assez quand
même assez grand assez flagrant parce
que tu m'as mis en confiance j'étais à
l'aise de parler dès le premier emploi
et puis on a eu pour allemande car à
coeur le plus long parce que personne ne
savait vraiment c'était quoi la formule
du patois
puis ça a été vraiment l'on me parler
longtemps donc c'est ça mérite une
visite et c'était une super conversation
puis tables rondes de ce que je sentais
que de s'intéresser à ces exemples mais
c'est ça mais mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui peut faire sentir ce match et
que quand je parle à quelqu'un souvent
l'impression que je suis pas du tout
intéressé c'est moi dire que je suis
maintenant
puis après cent sûr tant d'eau des taux
fait
la série d'entrevues que j'ai vu passer
je veux tout savoir du savoir est ce que
c'est toi qui choisis les invités c'est
toi qui mène l entrevue au complet d'un
monde à l'autre
comment te trouvais ça moi j'ai tripé
puis tu vois les caractères c'est une
des affaires c'est un mini ii x6 verront
pas grave que j'ai eu affaire au courant
de la saison c'est que moi on me
vraiment dit aïe
ils vont un segment c'est quelqu'un
c'est pour apprendre à connaître les
candidats puis je trouve que moi je la
prenais comme une mission personnelle de
vous humaniser aux yeux du public parce
que le public c'est normal
eux sont chez eux livres connaissent pas
ils peuvent vous rentrez dedans comme
bull sont très détaché et moi je voulais
vraiment c'est normal qu'il y ait des
êtres humains qui comprennent pas là
comment ils réagissent à certaines
situations mais quand tu connais son
histoire
c'est plus facile d'avoir d'empathie
pour moi c'est normal qu'un qu'ils
soient pas qu'ils aient réagi comme se
garde son maillot en tipi puis peu
importe le bagout en tout le monde de
son histoire puis moi je prenais
vraiment comme ça des fois je veux
sincèrement que tu me racontes et qui
puis ça m'intéresse depuis ses 6 pi tu
sais c'est que j'ai fait on peut citer
aussi je veux tout savoir c'est moi
naturellement j'ai le réflexe de quand
j'ai rencontré quand je réfléchis
demandé tu viens d'où c'est comme qui
étaient parents faisait quoi peut-être
les frères et soeurs je trouve que le
background familial tu étais comment
l'école de talent quelques secondes en
jeu toujours curieux de savoir
je trouve que tu comprend un peu mieux
la personne fait que fait t'on car
accord avec toi c'était subsistait
vraiment sensiblement ce que j'ai fait à
je veux tout savoir et non si on n'a pas
vraiment ton enfance puisque harry ces
cas précis j'ai compris ils sont comme
moi mais on peut pas vraiment faire un
mur avec 1 45 minutes de cotation c'est
normal j'ai compris ça mais reste que
l'homme et ont jeté plus plus ça
avançait plus j'étais comme quand même
j'ai envie d' humaniser et puis
maintenant le caractère avec karine je
pense que ça l'a aidé tpiy parce que si
ouverte
c'est vraiment grâce à elle à l'été game
2 s'ouvre et puis ça ça donne ça les
humaniser fait que cet été ce qui est
arrivé en fait c'est que moi ça fait un
bout de temps que les entrevues ça
m'intéresse vraiment beaucoup
puis des longues entrevues
parce que je trouve que tu peux aller
bien plus loin tu peux être plus nuancé
et tu peux prendre content tu peux
parler plein de sujets puis il ya
personne qui se tresser des tilles on
vient parler de départ un peu importe
quand même temps qui est parti très
sexuels passés comme on a le temps qu'on
veut forcer ce fait que fait moi j'ai
toujours été un gros fan des acteurs
studio des gros tidjane exact ça que ça
a toujours été quelques chose qui m'a
attiré j'ai fait un show à ma tv qui
s'appelait urbain ou state intérim a
jamais invité par de mire un thon
faisait trois entrevues fin qui est
quand même on commençait tout ce qui
était le fun c'est qu'ils ont commencé
vraiment en surface tranquillité qui tue
et nous on se ramasse est vraiment
parler plus loin je choisisse paterson
j'ai vraiment grandi là d'appui moi
quand j'ai commencé j'avais six jeunes
humoristes
donc j'avais de la difficulté à faire
des contrôles qu'ils étaient prêts à
mourir parce que j'avais tellement pas
que les gens voulaient que les gens
sachent que je devais me restait
aujourd'hui j'ai plus du tout cette
inquiétude le parce que justement je
pense tu pètes plus qu'un enfant dans la
vie je pense que les gens savent que je
fais des jokes sur un bois et drôle
via mon show je suis je suis drôle dit
je suis drôle dans la vie mais je
capable de tirer aussi puisqu'ils
étaient le fun cet été c'est que moi
j'ai rencontré des gens une qualité que
je trouve vraiment répandre chez
quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un de barras
quelqu'un qui fait les choses à sa
manière mais puis pour moi quelqu'un de
baala s'est pas quelqu'un de méchant
il fait juste les choses vraiment pour
lui même et qui fait qu' il
naturellement il attire en août et comme
puis pour moi mettons christiane
charette a fait s'affaisser a fait cette
femme le puits sur ce support inspirant
fac j'ai vraiment été dans cette lignée
là comme qui sait déjà que tu rencontré
comme un gadget merci que cette personne
ne me trouve cool c'est un peu ce que
j'ai rencontré tout des personnes comme
ce puits cottavoz de serge denoncourt à
sa fille audrey le sait varier puis j'ai
rencontré la mairesse valérie planté
fait que c'était super le fun
et puis j'ai beaucoup ce que j'ai aimé
c'est que dans ce rôle c'était pas moi
qui pointe chez c'était vraiment mon
invité kristen était hilarante
évidemment pierre-luc funk c'est fait
mais cette attaque on partait vraiment
de l'enfance de la personne son
cheminement ce qu'est ce que ses parents
faisaient de sa famille c'était quoi
puis on monte jusqu'à sa vie petites
voitures jaunes rouges à votre question
mais c'est losc et mettons ada qui était
sur rodeo médias sociaux à muffins
privat cherche pas qu'à me faisait un
petit dossier de recherche un joueur de
moins de paix john de un ou deux pages
vraiment faim avait-elle place à
l'étudiant tel truc et des trucs à
savoir des trucs à le dip ce qui fait
que je voulais je me préparais mais pas
trop parce que je vais rendre sur mon
invité qui parle parce que facture et ce
bien plus intéressant c'est fait que
c'est vraiment très très très naturelle
soit la mairesse c'est celle que je
connaissais le moins ça a été une des
entrevues les plus sincères parce que
c'est vraiment comme je sais pas grand
lac - si tu viens drouin explique mon
porte également ta vie puis j'ai
vraiment aimé ça pis j'aime et j'ai aimé
c'est cette espèce d'intimité lieu de
communiquer à quelqu'un vraiment
longtemps puis fait savoir me téléphone
assurant quelque chose que je consommais
enfant né sous x
huawei est complètement à fond je
tenterai de préparer mon année 2010 9
sec un bout s'est satisfait que j'ai la
tournée m'ont chômeurs fr qui comme bar
en bas toute l'année
puis c'est vraiment la seule année
tournée ont fini fin 2010 9 début 2020
puis j'ai commencé à faire des shows de
quoi doit donc un show créé des pros que
je trouve pas la faille
c'est pour se remettre en danger aussi
déjà une situation je pourrais
facilement énorme et partout fait un peu
m'asseoir sur ce que j'ai plutôt que la
tournée pas que c'est facile mais le
show était critique j'ai pu diriger le
travail encore le show mais la grosse
majorité ce travail est fait faute
tandis que le mans en marquer puis mois
c'est 1,8 s'apprend faut aussi que je
suis comme jean-marc sur scène les gens
plus d'attentes pas slim connaissent ça
m'arrivait pas se glisser de farah qui
attend le bus après ça il faut que les
joueurs soient drôles que les gens
s'attendent à quelque chose d'étrange et
à l'inversé pour garder cette espèce de
frêche ni cela de ferraille j'embarquais
que rien vous le savez
jc ont fait que j'ai ma tournée j'ai su
que ces deux choses très différentes et
a traversé j'aimerais continuer à faire
des entrevues
parce que je trouve ce moment disait que
le plus impressionnant mois d'animaux
restos c'est caen qui sort de son texte
qu'il y ait vraiment drôle pour votre
métier
le texte est important pitt situe le
travail puis avec soit parfait mais puis
aussi comme public
quand tu sors je suis venu voir
d'ailleurs justement c'était super bon
bravo
charlie est extrêmement brillant bris
puis justement télé petit moment où est
ce que tu fais du bac une forte avec le
monde dans le public
en tant qu attend spectateurs dit je
tendrais une vivre un moment unique
c'est parce que la joke ou le punch que
tu as faite le il est arrivé là à cause
que lui ai dit ça puisse arriver une
fois tout ça c'est vraiment vraiment
impressionnant d'être capable d'être
drôle
on dispose d'un dommage antibes en fait
c'est qu'ils arrivent succès c'est une
belle bête lui moss et c'est un grumeau
manenti comme tu fais de la musique et
c'est un gros du nom de manière à la
musique ça l'industrie avant difficile
mais tu peux être bon jeune à musique
c'est surtout quelqu'un talent show où
on pratique la qualité mais je te dis
pas que c'est plus facile c'est parce
que vous aimez naturellement des gens
qui chantent très bien passé comment est
hôtesse dont le c'est extraordinaire
l'humour c'est vraiment un grand nom
s'est vraiment il y en a qui ont des
talents naturels évidemment départ mais
faut que tu écrives foot qui reste
encore discret et ça peu de mille
manières petit peu écrire en impro sur
scène ces mots cachés michôd quart
d'heure j'écris pendant une heure et
demie c'est l'écriture même très
différentes il faut que ce qui est qui
et qui peuvent se trouver l'équilibré
doit de faire faut que les choses soient
écrits mais faut que tu fous que tu
sentes que ça prend fois je te le compte
fait il faut que vraiment que tu sois
trop vraiment dans le moment chaque fois
c'est que j'aime de l'humour sexy
d'humain à humain cyril c'est le faut
que je sois là si je suis moins dans ma
peau la jav pas un bon show t'nb ssl
afin aussi de l'impro c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense mon short court
adroit que maintenant qu'ils ont vu mes
deux choses plus et mettons tout
quadruplé six matches c'est parce qu'il
ya un côté impressionnant
à chaud le cas pas dans l'autre mais
l'autre c'est le fruit d'un travail de
trois ans et dix mois on retravaille
aurait écrit un fax et c'est juste deux
trucs différents
james les mixer puis l'imposent parfaite
pour tous les humoristes
mais je sais pas c'est même moi je tends
gecko m'entraîne vraiment travailler ce
côté là de faire kata c'est quoi cette
espèce de voile que pour emprunter qui
est l'impro c'est hier j'étais à
saint-eustache puis en début de show il
ya un gars qui était debout dit
[Musique]
mais si j'ai gelé super bien entre parce
que je les prie vraiment avec un grain
de sel jerry comme relax les potes
démoli g7 comme doute baisser les bras
on n'est pas à rendre le contient comme
j'étais relax puis ça a été super
positif ça a été un moment super le fun
finalement mais ça m'est arrivé aussi
d'avoir des moments où moi j'étais plus
fatigué jetez plus irritables puis
d'avoir des gens qui parlent de vraiment
snap est peut-être trop vite et ça que
c'est un couteau à deux tranchants
l'impro ça peut être super payants comme
ça prend un peu de démolir ces faits que
c'est bien mais c'est myspace puis je
m'étais dit on chausse avait trois
quatre ans tout le travail mais les pros
il ya du travail là dedans aussi
comment un huissier de jazz mettons que
jacquot visé - ça fait des années qu'ils
pratiquent ces gammes s'est offert tout
ça fait dix ans que tu écris des jo de
salt améliorée
c'est comme la culmination de tout ce
travail là aussi c'est de faire
confiance à ton instinct aussi je pense
que c'est le plus fort smith et ceux qui
le plus apparent aussi six mois j'ai
appris que j'étais capable de faire ce
en animant aux jo qui selon eux du mot
fait qu'à chaque semaine il faut que du
nouveau matériel va commander je
commençais toujours son rendement
d'assez qui les nouveaux qui jouent eux
qui sont les personnes qui sont jamais
venus ici de me parler que ces
personnels ont mené réalisé créé mac est
capable d'être faune et la dap il faut
faire confiance à son instinct et puis
moi je restais du moment où tu connais
l'envi petit mot sur scène
pas mal la même personne 6 puis juste
pas que c'est mieux que ceux qui ont des
gros personnage et cinquième mois c'est
l'humour qui m'attire le plus mais je
m'en reste référé si les êtres humains
que quand j'écoute est sur scène et or
d'assen j'ai l'impression que j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'ils sont très
très très cinquième fois qu'il ya une
espèce de faire confiance à son instinct
me servait tellement sortie de la marque
souvent c'est dans des corps pots à lait
dans des situations supporter ce sport
est il des shows froide est chaud il ya
presque personne afin d'aller chercher
le monde de même puis aussi c'est de
donner aussi l'importance au public de
faire acheter une partie intégrante de
mon spectacle vous littéralement un
chausse du mot ça se peut pas ça en
public
c'est connecter un dialogue je te lance
un gars qui menace un rib sait on pas un
gîte de même puis plus je t'en donne
plus tu vas me donner puis plus à voir
venez c'est vraiment du donnant donnant
moi ce que j'aime du show c'est que ces
poésies comme surligner mais moi je
trouve que en parlons public rapidement
dans mon show écrit bien faire c'est que
ça l'inclût vraiment de fin on a beau
être d'une grande sagesse rétabli et
pourra plus tôt aussi mais en bout de
ligne jaune et moi le plus beau
compliment qu'on peut faire ce vendée
j'avais l'impression team chose que je
sais pas et sopi c'est vraiment le fun
ça crée des moments super vraiment le
tpiy je me surprends moi même celle au
jeudi les gags les plus drôles tu es
vraiment deborah renner montchaude crux
qui espère c'est que je raconte des
enfants que je pensais pour raconter ses
enfants qui me viennent de l'obtenir
j'enregistre genfit qui fatigue et je
tenterai d'écrire mon prochain show
comme ceux qui jeûnaient ou sur moi un
effet de 4,4 show d'une heure et quart
en 1h30 enfin que ça fait pas mal de
stock et
les années son papa mais tout était
comme quand je les réécoute c'est
horrible à écouter parce que moi je sors
de sam fisher sur la drôle elle reste
est malade mais ça ne s'arrêtait pas
j'écoute mon dieu c'est inégal
c'est dégueulasse la beauté de la foi
aussi celle imperfections de sur le
qu'il reçut pas elle rigole vraiment
vraiment le trip cassidy tu as
l'impression de vivre un moment unique
s'est étalée sur une heure et demie qui
fait que ce à quoi est il ya plein de
bonnes pistes que j'ai que je peux
travailler puisque d'après avec ce que
je pars en grèce le sait je n'ai qu'à le
jeu pop le jeu pour écouter ce
tranquille france est intéressant si je
préfère travailler se dit éventuellement
ça va ça va donner un nouveau show messi
c'est cool tu sais moi ça m'impressionne
tout le temps tu as des idoles c'est
fred pellerin dans ma vie puis dans tout
ce qui représente le pire
regardez ce que je te comme été freiné
ce genre d'êtres humains que
l'impression que c'est pas son premier
tour de piste is it et du monde de même
que des cols il caché des choses qu'il
s'agit puis emmené jeu l'a vu allez
merci était venu faire une conférence
dans un de mes cours qui était un cours
de littérature québécoise
puis lui ce qu'il disait c'est que il
voulait pas finalement il a fini par le
faire mais il était réticent mettre ses
spectacles sur dvd ou six spectacles sur
cd parce qu'il disait moi ce que j'aime
c'est que chaque spectacle est différent
à chaque fois
ces puits puis quand que j'ai réalisé
que de prendre une oeuvre d'or une offre
d'assen et de la mettre sur album
l'effigié de la figer dans le temps ça
peut nuire un petit peu a l'expérience
et puis souvent et maintenant ils
veulent maintenant c'est la grosse mode
des spéciaux sur netflix est ce que tu
vois un humoriste et segula des stand-up
comique américain souvent des geeks
fondus croire world pas mal à dépanner
calme et à ne plus que d'autres puis là
c'est cadeau qu'est ce c'est figé dans
le temps c'est ça c'est le spécial j'ai
l'impression que ça enlève un petit peu
à l'attrait d'aller voir un spectacle
c'est parce que moi mettons je veux te
voir toi un spectacle
c'est pas ça pas d'un accord global pas
un état mais je veux te voir toi puis
comme chez qu'est ce que je vais voir
cette soirée le personnes d'eau qui va
le voir rapport le monde son empire
c'est quoi ça ça comme un attrait pour
moi on dirait ce qui bouge trouve des
spectacles live c'est que ces d'humain à
humain
ça va jamais taupe et cécilia trop
d'énergie c'est trop plus un fait acquis
si il ya un fou rire d'une salle dispose
de quoi qu'il ya un malaise
ici pas de quoi refaire c'est tellement
puissant compte comme sentir 100 200 300
mille personnes cinq hommes comme rire
forte
il ya quelque chose de vraiment faire là
dedans puis je pense que maintenant ce
qui est beau maintenant d'un special
écrit pu bien travailler c'est qu'on
peut aller vraiment plus loin il ya des
shows si je comprends dans son allée
voir un show de quad work tu vois
vraiment pour rien
voilà pour rire te faire divertir je
sais pas ce qui va se passer l'humoriste
non plus ça qu'il dit d'affaires puisse
raconter des choses g normalement tu
irais pas mais le tuerie parce qu'il ya
un consciemment ne se rend pas compte de
cet impressionnant puis tout le monde
sait que rien dans ce cachot écrit ait
quelque chose derrière il ya quelque
chose derrière il ya une pensée c'est il
ya des choletais comme à ce titre de
l'opt et comme c'est sa grande dalle
comme un bon film c'est comme ça résonne
pendant deux trois quatre jours une
semaine 5 falcon mettre fin comme tir
pense beaucoup comme écouter un bon
album tu es cannet en intérim à betty
que ça va pas arriver je pense avec un
chèque cadeau on sait que du
divertissement c'est de l'or mais c'est
un stunt ses tripes entier parce que des
shows comme scan à gatsby est fait avec
nanette sur netflix amène sa tête
rentrer dedans mais comme un terroir
cuisse et lotus fait la puissance
d'avoir écrit ce d'avoir travaillé ça
pendant des mois des années de mettre en
mots tout ce qu'ils habitent tout le
jouet la hargne qui l'habite autant
qu'un fred pellerin qui a une histoire à
raconter puis qui est tellement de
charisme que ça je pense que c'est ça la
différence puisque ça peut être
intéressant de caen il ya des shows plus
écrit que d'autres c'est normal que
savary a toujours un 10 15% que va
varier nos soir l'autre y en a que c'est
moins que seul puis un accès plus mais
les roadshows va souvent être le moins
fait pour moi ces piges immeuble j'ai
jamais capté mon show comme je n'ai pas
sorti pis je le sais que la journée va
sortir je vois le détester je le sais
c'est quelque chose surfant sur image
sur ma baisse parce que aussi c'est un
peu sexiste à long terme c'est dans le
sens où tu fais la tournée finie ça
continue à rouler mais en fait c'est que
le capter moi j'aimerais ça ma tournée
je le sais car termine le 3 janvier 2020
mettons c'est madonna da de chaud puis
j'aimerais ce que la captation sorte le
lendemain fa com
heijmans c'est terminé c'est dur que
j'ai conduit jamais de ma vie merci
bonsoir c'est disponible à tout le monde
ceux qui ont pas les moyens de les voir
des spectacles ou ceux qui ont pensé à
sucre vous l'avez vous savez d'apremont
pour le prochain aussi des gens qui
m'ont jamais vu un chaux de fonds comme
hakim est finalement ses coéquipiers
mais c'est normal que l'expérience est
vraiment moindre vraiment comme un roi
de la musique live si j'ai évidemment
que sur cd karkwa c'est magique mais un
show mais c'est sa départ des dépenses
et même il ya des spectacles
d'humoristes jeu comme tu es tu
commences puis il y en a qui sait que
drôle mais reste que moi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration puisse aimer ses musées
tous mes préférés le gobelet les gens
drôles fakir cemac biglia qui est un
show qui s'appelle my girlfriend's
boyfriend
je connaissais 0 quand j'ai commencé
chaud puis à fin c'était mon numéro
préféré gérer la danse la piste est beau
que ce soit écrit comme ça il ya un
petit moment d'être au milieu
carrie fort il ya des gros rires mais
c'est pas ça qui résonne le plus fort
d'un spectacle c'est toute l'histoire
derrière pitt au delà la vulnérabilité
pylônes et et puis la sensibilité
quémande
de quelque chose de très drôle ces
factions semaine sur semaine ça va être
cool
l'école de l'humour pour ce pourrait
être entouré de monde juste drôle c'est
ya un côté mes meilleurs amis du monde
j'ai rencontré le 4 novak david blocage
100 breton c'est des gens qui vont être
avec moi jusqu'à ma mort je fais que
palm a comme vous à l'université où je
me suis posté à une université où quand
et où sa musique c'est qu'en quantité
mais à faire beaucoup de musique quand
on a tous les deux se montrent qu'ils
ont la même passion que toi terminé
c'est comme telle impression il n'y a
pas de fonds à la conversation tu peux
avoir sur ces sujets le peekton pas de
parler des trains
là la petite nuance à les connais le
monde sait que penser maintenant à la
personne la plus drôle ou la plus la
haute a voté qu'à son honneur mais
seulement quatorze personnes comme sur
ces lots est très lourd et très intense
pour que moi soit mais depuis je suis
capable je bous de plus en plus calme
dans ma vie moi l'humour me kam parce
que mon besoin d'attention et comme
concentrer sur la scène aménagée comme
un espèce de manques qui est très comblé
qui fait en sorte qu'un ménage et dans
mon quotidien j'ai pu besoin d'avoir le
spotlight mais vraiment potes et puis je
ne cherche pas dans le quotidien ou
secondaire mais il ya des gens qui
devaient me détestais mon dieu qu'est
l'eau mais fax et sautillent à 14
personnes mais oui en effet il ya
quelque chose de tripes ans a partagé ce
puits c'est vraiment intense pis la
tournée les cadets le mot s'étoffe moi
je trouve ça vraiment dur puis mettons
84 e mail
mais cette offre parce que mes amis tu
es vraiment vraiment bon et puis moi je
ne sais pas mauvais mais ce n'est pas
bon non plus faste et comme je t'ai est
excellent mais pourquoi moins que ses os
et 7,6 fixé comme mais ça a été la
meilleure chose parce que moi ça me
j'ouvrais la tournée puis ouvrir un show
du monde c'est tough
surtout quand et pas très drôle était
pas connu un cas précis mais ça a été la
meilleure chose puisque moi pendant un
an
antenne de choses à me rentrer dedans
même quand c'était fait un show qui
était froid pour moi c'était mort quant
aux choletais la folie quand moi je
débarquais je te contente plus avancé
plus le plafond fendait quand mondiale
et moi je t'ai fait que ça a été
vraiment au fait mais ça arrive et
j'arrivais dans un bar avec le drive mg
vous allez fauconnerie mais avait un
animateur qui venait de réchauffer tout
le monde j'ai remarqué puis ça riait
d'elle débuté à l'école et le monde cinq
minutes cinq minutes c'est ce que ça
prend quand et pas drôle pour commencer
peut-être mais cette dernière chose
c'est ce qui m'a permis aussi de devenir
un bon animateur de soirées du monde en
marquer de faire des premières parties
de ne pas voir paraître fade et karpov
monde et croire du fret je n'ai vu une
puis un autre à caster j'ai pu par le
titre s'est fait que pete voit
maintenant les bars toute l'expérience
du live c'est pas mal la meilleure chose
qui m'a aidé pour la finale dotée
incapable de gérer toutes les éléments
rares littéralement frais c'est ce type
généralement la fin alimenter 10 minutes
pour livrer tout ça il ya plein
d'éléments du timbre s'essaye avec
pretty angot qui crie quelque chose il
ya une fan qui loge qui fait chaud il ya
plein d'enfants à gérer marc bling est
ce que le monde rit c'est tout ce qui
est important c'est fait mais les débuts
là dedans c'est vraiment campements sont
pas loin juste un peu connaissent point
sont ils connaissent pas justement si tu
arrives là puis il faut que je fasse ses
preuves
une fois qu'ils étaient connus c'est
plus facile mais les gens ils vont les y
savent qu'ils vont réussir passé de
difficulté très différent quand et quand
t'es pas connu
tu peux juste surprendre à deux pas de
pression notamment quand j'ouvrais je
fais j'ai fait des premières parties
d'adeeb avec l idée puis j'ai fait quand
même tôt dans ma carrière je sortis des
cadets le monde 2013 j'ai commencé à
tourner qu'à 10 en 2014
c'était rapide si j'étais pas très bon
je t'ai pas très nuancé je t'ai je
parlais vitu par l'effort puis c'était
un espèce de je savais que c'était juste
bien parce que défendre vraiment parti
c'était bon les gens les gens qui
t'aiment vont se rappeler toi les gens
qui t'ont pas aimer vont oublier fa cup
tandis que 5 au début et l'espèce de ski
et off c'est que t'es pas au foot et
c'est ça qui étoffent secteur il ya
personne qui veut qui tu veux
puis quand tu commences à travailler en
milieu public on dirait que c'est un peu
faire du porte à porte bien ils montrent
qu'ils sont choqués que tu fasses ta job
le reçois comme pourquoi qui est là pour
contrôler voire télé un peu comme un
petit peu changé de poste mais à ce que
je mange jamais publié que j'ai pas le
choix de français je suis désolé mais tu
es pour obliger de mai mais nak
au début c'est un espèce de il ya
personne qui tu veux tu peux juste
surprendre pas de pression maintenant de
rien il faut qu une espèce de ce qui est
bien aussi c'est moi j'ai toujours été
vraiment heureux de mon travail je te
retrouver tellement chanceux de français
puis je trouve c'est trippant france
appuie activement tous les lundis aux jo
qui était comme mon stress des justes
qui est du monde en salle puis mémo du
monde estime en tout cas donné la
pression quand tu es connu ça souhaite
c'est que les gens ont des attentes qui
fait en sorte que toi inconsciemment tu
peux être plus nerveux parce que comme
français venir rôder du nouveau stock
secte of kain typo connu ce programme 10
programme fac est là c'est juste eu pète
la gueule c'est comme un ferment de
ditan d'ordonnancé moi j'essaye de stock
pie x qui est une espèce de c'est juste
je pense que les deux s'équilibrent
ces pyromanes essaie juste de faire mais
moi mettons j'ai vu des grands
humoristes rodez du strict et pu tuer
nancy michaud may rousseau vraiment
a-rod d'un festival devant 10000
personnes vont sûrement être gêné de
rodez d'un bar où il ya soixante-quinze
personnes qu'un cheveu
juste j'ai dû tandis que l'on puisse
calmer le faire moi c'est lorsque aussi
les shoots corps droit commun de ces
deux faits de me ramener à base de fer
comme hyman 6 heures et est du toc c'est
pas facile puis c'est pas tout le temps
drôle puis c'est pas grave puis du
travail puisqu'il voit puisse continuer
puis c'est qu'un peu dans d'enlever
cette espèce de dates de crainte le
parce que faut que tu y as et ce qui est
un gros secteur s'est travesti de stoked
mais des fautes qu'on va aller [ __ ]
commun c'est drôle
pourquoi mais il ya quelque chose a
vraiment vraiment le fun a tenté
d'acheter des votes ont chaud la
première chose qui m'a frappé c'est à
quel point tout le monde dans la salle
mort semblait tout le monde c'est vrai
mais ton public est vraiment ciblé puis
c'est sûr que c'est une décision
consciente dans un sens parce que oui
puis non ton chaud et quand même pacte
et de référence tout nés en 91 même
comme moi dans ma fac
toutes les références à pokémon harry
potter à tout ceux qui ici comme si moi
avec ma blonde ça parle et puis
justement ce qu'on s'y dit après c'est
la première fois qu'on va voir un show
où est ce qu'on est vraiment le public
si ces deux générations
si un phénomène qui nous vaut je pense
non mais c'est pour toi maintenant c'est
la première que tu vis cette expérience
là mais je pense que met-on qu'un loup
josé sorti son premier show s'adresse à
sa génération des jobs de son premier
shoot et une job de vuarnet ja
comprennent un poste une marque de linge
que lui avec un tgv que les nordiques
puis ce genre la fin je pense que c'est
normal que mettons les humoristes qu'on
a vu quand qu'on était plus jeune
bien sûr avec internet tout ça change
nous quand même on a grandi avec
vraiment la télé les humoristes convoya
télé mince et des humoristes qui
s'adressait plus à nos parents doivent
dans sa renault parents avaient pendant
trente et un de ces faits qui est à peu
près à ton âge puis si je me reste
quatre et c'est vraiment je pense que
c'est juste un cycle qui changent plus
dans notre tour puis c'est c'est
fascinant comment aussi
une espèce de six mois je quand tu
commences à lui montre commence dans un
bar des morts mais c'est une corde
qu'ils aient 18 ans et plus et qui très
universitaire un peu importe où tu joues
le jeu me tombent les soirées du monde à
montréal
c'est très universitaire puis les jeunes
commencent à travailler fax et très
18,34 vraiment vraiment très ciblée vers
un point
inconsciemment ton écriture voit dans
cette direction là moi je suis rentré
d'un bar j'avais je sortirai qu'à
limoges avait 21 ans quand ça va bien
veut pas mener inconsciemment mais tu
t'adresses à ton monde s'active oui elle
est là dans ma manie cartney à jouer
quand cela fera date et les bloquer il
ya déjà des gens un peu plus vieux ou
plus jeunes qui viennent hanter sa belle
forme retrouves ton écriture mais sans
se dénaturer les impacts et je me gêne
pas de faire une job de pokémon mais je
serai pas un numéro sur les pokemons et
puis je pense que dans mon show c'est
sûr que les références car il sait que
c'est tellement fort en nous que si j'ai
deux jobs d'harry potter dans mon show
mais les gens m'en parlent beaucoup dit
tandis que j'ai un numéro sur
l'infidélité que si ça peut s'adresser à
vraiment un public plus large mais en se
savent c'est normal que je pense que
c'est genre de truc où curieusement me
tombe je pensais pas du tout que radio
enfin dans mon chou même ma mère
écoutait radio enfin fait que ma mère
allait la référence des pokémon à la
référence de radio enfin les gens qui
l'ont pas si les ados d'aujourd'hui gens
qui ont 12 et 18 19 à 20 ans ce qui est
pas bien mais plus jeune que moins de 20
ans d'âge et 26 team et il pleut ils ont
pompé dans une galaxie près de chez vous
trépignez fait que ces gens-là fin où ce
que c'est le petit décalage qui est ce
que motive en phase i à tout un aimant
pour les jeunes du canton je m'adresse
aux gens de mon âge
vraiment vraiment je pense que ça peut
raisonner plus large qui font que ces
sites et puis c'est là aussi où des fois
j'ai regardé et d'être authentique sur
sajoo est très zen à être très sincère
très vrai puis
ce que je trouve intéressant que c'est
beaucoup a dit bhl qui me fait réaliser
ça mais c'est quand un numéro est ancré
dans une émotion ça va résonner vraiment
plus fort c'est-à-dire que peu importe
l'anecdote que j'avais un numéro avant
où j'ai raconté peu importe la météo et
la première fois que tu vois dans mon
show j'ai une anecdote sur la point la
première fois que j'étais vraiment sous
dans ma ville puis mes parents m'ont
sont venus chercher et puis tu en colère
cp berne - sauf quand c'est arrivé c'est
un drame le genre c'était je m'en suis
voulu pendant des mois le de chelsea
léger la distance pour en parler puisque
harry c'est qu'il ya quand même le sous
texte de ce que j'ai vécu de la honte
oui et inconsciemment tout le monde ce
langage avec une honte c'est lorsque mon
anecdote à te fait rire mais
inconsciemment je pense qu'elle peut se
rattacher à plus long est ce parce que
le langage des émotions c'est un langage
vraiment universelle tout le monde
connaît faire quelque chose qui me fait
profondément rire mais ça va résonner
avec quelqu'un mais la peine la joie
l'acompte nemisz et lorsque je trouve ça
intéressant à faire moi des fois moniste
une question je me suis posé en dessous
de chaque number pis c'est pas éclipser
pas sur les nippes des fois il faut pas
ouvrir cinq la sphère le site vraiment
juste des jo mais quand il ya de
l'émotion en dessous si le je pense que
ça peut raisonner plus fort puis je
pense que évidemment que c'est so lu
ment aussi la grosse différence puisque
et dur notamment musique ça s'exporte
très bien même si le mot c'est dur à
exporter parce que c'est très ciblé ses
traits culturels fac c'est sûr que si je
fais une job de verglas mais côté
je n'ai pas besoin d'aller bien loin
d'un barreau de l'au-delà 40 puis
c'était comme mode était de descendre
c'est fini le titre c'est l'os que la
culture peut reste restreint le moment
même temps ça fait en sorte que tous à
table on a vite fait encore plus forte
en fait c'est comme juste de genji jeu
suffisamment petit j'ai déjà pointu mais
je veux accuser quand même aux plus
jeunes aux plus vieux que le juge ait
perdu puis c'est d'accepter c'est aussi
en effet c'est mon choix je m'amusais au
sipi ce programme était quatre fois
toutes ces messieurs qui est quatre
chemins et répit mais c'est juste que
j'aime pas ce trop divisé la corde fixe
pour seule source important quand même
de rassembler le monde puis me permettre
de faire du yoga ou potter pas ça
m'amuse at elle expliqué après pisam
fait est une des personnes qui a le plus
de références de culture populaire que
j'ai connu c'est je m'appelle à rodez à
chaque fois que tu viens nous voir à
travers une nouvelle ère moi j'ai quand
même au niveau la culture plage quand
même une bonne connaissance de pop
culture de nos générations du moindre
fait souvent âgé comprenait mais des
fois tard avec des trucs que je cachais
jeu spore terne
il ya encore une autre une autre
référence que je connais pas c'est
toujours utile - booba c'est en
travaillant
tonton humour python affaire qui fait
une espèce de banksy et de culture ou
qui tu es non je projetais mais je sais
pas si un peu inconscient ouais mais tu
vois c'est seulement au début si cela
quand j'anime aux jo qui je m'adresse à
presque juste des universitaires fait
que
c'est cela une joke d'harry potter ou
des rouleaux fruits raisins vtc le fond
même année c'est selon monique de balle
de pikachu
mais c'est aussi juste de chine
mais j'ai pas le temps de référence que
ce team émeutes on sait que friends
mettons c'est un grounding dans ma vie
fac c'est sûr que s'ils se pose de coupe
ça me fait prendre comme la quantité de
fausses feuilles comme dans 13 pays la
main et j'ai percuté jaumin cependant je
raconte quand même fait rimer norman et
ça devient une espèce aussi que j'ai la
plus fluide d'harry potter que je suis
juste parce que ben il suffit que jean
par une faute deux pistes on a fait un
show là dessus nous autres on ne fêtera
pas tort comme eddy show un show des
stand-up des sketches sur ce sujet fait
qu'on le connaît bien et on trippe pour
vrai mamane et ça fait en sorte que ben
par la bande que 1 800 e poteau avec là
on va parler de l'eau potable
ça fait comment n'ai je parle tout le
temps de me porter fait que je l'avais
plus fluide que je suis ça me dérange
poti mais enfin que j'ai jamais vraiment
trop pensé l'oissu ce que des fois je
pense que je pourrais devenir le doute
connu qui se met à juste content et des
anecdotes de shojo connu l'été l'autre
fausse telle ou telle personne
je suis passé sur ce point important de
vivre des chics types de rester très
parce que c'est facile aux monnaies de
faire comme moi même sommes j'ai rien à
raconter j'ai juste comme je juste la
télé et puis je trouve fois-ci tout le
temps intéressait raconter des anecdotes
de coulisses tu fais que c'est là où je
trouve encore une fois de voyager de
sortie d'haze on a confiance et de quoi
aller aller à quelques potes jamais tips
ça fait en sorte que les moniteurs des
choses à raconter qu'ils sont vraiment
très content c'est ok mais la culture
c'est ça les références un show je pense
que piste des fossés des réflexes de
débutants riche choqué quand tu
commences à l'umons les deux trucs les
plus faciles à aller chercher c'est la
vulgarité plat référence
le nem drop s'est laissé des réflexes
qui fait défaut c'est juste un réflexe
de faire fort que ça me prend rire jojo
d'europe est simple je sais que ça
remarche été mais des fois tu peut
creuser un peu plus loin on peut les
trouver votre stratégie au niveau de mon
devoir c'est ce même si c'est juste des
faits
4 hussain job2day dans mon show j'ai pas
un homme beurre lathus des petits clins
d'oeil puis c'est aussi pour aussi un
peu accusé le fait de beaucoup de gens
qui sont en métal qui m'ont connu sauf
que cette fois comme la garde oui j'ai
fait sur jérôme il ya d'autres choses
pis allons-y mais je ferme pas les yeux
là tu sais le faire et je suis prête à
faire en vue dont animateurs d'euros dit
mme parlais tantôt de te mettre en
danger avec ton nouveau avec le choc
frôle work pis ça me semble être une
trame narrative pour toi qui revient
souvent de ton parcours c'est toujours
faire quelque chose qui met pas dans ta
zone de confort
je pense notamment à écrire un livre
ouais quelque chose qui n'est pas
nécessairement ce que tu faisais type
puis pourquoi tu cherches le temps sur
ce qui se passe en fait tu le sais que
je pense est un peu inconscient oui je
pense pipeauté kaman et je veux pas te
dire ça mais je me suis posé déjà la
question c'est une super bonne question
puisque 1 pourquoi mon nouveau morceau
de ma vie c'est en six séances mais d'en
décider
des plages comme jamais dans des
situations j'ai pas besoin de soutien
aux enfants mais je pense que c'est
c'est maintenant aux 17es s'est créé le
lycée charles cros drogue si c'est plein
de trucs comme ça
ma vie me fascine parce que puis je
trouve ça le fun comme à vue me fascine
parce que je tripe si mais je me ramasse
dans des places je pensais jamais
vraiment cessé puis je pense que quand
tu te fais il ya des gros projets xandre
des grosses montagnes quand tu les
attaques
puis tu es accepte moi du moins j
accepte je pense surtout en pensant le
sentiment que je vive après com com a
attaqué un groupe swing et puis la
douche d'après game de hockey khl et ces
gens-là fois où tu fais a écrit un livre
c'est vraiment trippant moto je sais que
les gens qui écrivent des livres sait
déjà que j'admire et que que je tiens
vraiment en grande estime
je suis capable hickstead personne je
pense pas mais essayons le et il rien je
pense que pour accomplir des choses moi
j'ai besoin des deadlines j'ai besoin
d'avoir besoin de telles dates
enfin que ça m'est tombé sa tête ces
sauvages accepte un peu en oublier un
peu ce que ça implique une fois dedans
puis cod5 chaussée quand tu monteras
montant que c'est off puis ces groupes
sont mais rendue de l'autre bateau
regarde t comme j'étais capable de faire
ça puisque ici que c'est qu'on voudrait
c'est comme des check points tandis que
cisco est le suivant du capa de phase i
what's next
puis c'est comme ça que moi je
m'améliore si fait que justement le
titre comme c'est tout des petits tas
fois que je me repose tout le temps
parce que quand c'est paul von un petit
bout de temps mais qu'il accomplit par
herman et tarif global c'est vraiment
trippant le fait qu'on dirait que
j'essaie d'avancer de même pu sceller
chaude quart d'heure que benmosche un
crime c'est quand même admirable c'est
pas facile à mettre en place une
solution paraissent eux aussi le sais
j'ai rien à faire sur les gens
embarquent si je me plante c'est ton
l'erreur j'ai tout cas je dis bien moche
avec une espèce de le livre ou si
c'était ce que je quittais d'offres
c'est que j'avais pas le temps de
l'écrire c'est mais j'ai pas le choix de
prendre le temps d'écrire puisqu'ils
jugent que je trouve dur du livre puis
si tu veux savoir de quoi je parle c'est
que monet faut que tu acceptes de
j'aurais voulu continuer à travailler
mais c'est ça aussi le foot il est salée
puis il est imparfait
encore une fois ça fait son charme moi
je trouve mais c'est ça c'est dit
puisque ce qu'est ce qui est ce que ce
que je trouve patiemment plaisant de
l'écriture c'est que c'est quelque chose
de très personnel d'être seul dans ta
bulle puis tu écris mais je vous avoue
je m'ouvre encore jeux move beaucoup sur
scène mais je me vois encore plus quand
j'écris parce que j'ai l'impression tout
seul que je me parle juste à moins que
je vois bien plus loin puis je le vis
tout seul puis quand je l'envoie le
lecteur l'achète pili tout seul
cuerrier un espace d'intimité qui se
crée l'auteur puis le lectorat qui est
vraiment super ce qu'ils font en sorte
que les gens qui arrivent à moncheaux
peut enfin le temps qui me font si mon
livre il ya un espèce de petit afad
omagad se dire entre leurs doigts
c'est cette fois quelque chose demain
spéciale de la journée que je les vois
ton show j'ai lu ton livre tu es une
journée thématique du temps
puis deux choses premièrement on
remarque qu'il ya des choses qui sont
dans le livre qui reviennent dans le
show les chaussures wild son livre
numéro un mais
avec des différences des petites nuances
sans moyens dans le fond dans ce show
tient dans une chose mon faux le punch
priorise donc faut que ce soit drôle et
il s'est plus rapide dans un show aux
montants ce que dans le livre
ce que je trouve le fond de ce numéro se
mettre tout le livre peu plus la même
journée fac tu laisse entraîner dans le
show ça roule dans le livre je prends
mon temps je raconte petit moment je me
sens puisque je pense parce que dans le
show je pèse pas trop sur ce clou le
mais quand même je trouve que le number
et vaut la peine d'être comme moi je
trouve qu'ils et deuxièmement ça c'est
la question séjour et on se demande tout
le temps parce que sinon celle d'anton
chauffe dans son livre c'est quoi la
porte d'autres fictions d'autobiographie
là dedans mais je me suis posé la
question le ton dans livre est ce que
est ce que je change le nom de mon
personnage c'est parce que c'est moins
personnage c'est jérémy puis je me suis
posé la question parce que mon enfant le
livre quand j'ai accepté ce qu'ils
voulaient c'était la base là l'acda
commandes s'étaient on veut les
histoires de guerre dans le sens où on
veut sa part d'une relation en dgo peu
importe que cela passe évidemment par
différents
on verra peut comprendre et moi je suis
partie vraiment avec l'idée de parler
d'amitié en garçons c'est vous deux vous
êtes des amis depuis la 5ème année il ya
beaucoup d'amour l'a d'ailleurs beaucoup
de fraternité
puis il ya de quoi de vraiment fort dans
l'amour masculin dans l'amour basculer
dans l'amitié masculine dont on parle
mais dont on sait comme le boss qui se
disent je t'aime on le dit on le dit un
produit augmente hymne qui m
j'ai des amis à qui je trouve ça super
important de leur dire et puis c'est
vraiment important pis c'est vraiment le
fun pichot que c'est le genre d'amitié
qui est assez unique t'es pas comme moi
j'ai jamais dit ça fait assez drôle
parce que on se connaît depuis tellement
longtemps
je pense qu'on s'est jamais serré la
main parce qu'on commence à face à ne
jamais commencer sa saison
totalement quelque chose de puissant un
partage on se comprend bien tu une
grosse gueule c'est tellement simple et
flux et des esprits un partage qui est
gigantesque tes pieds fac dans le livre
moi je n'ai pas écrit en ordre gelé
vraiment puis ma vie c'est raconter des
histoires un petit aussi peur fait comme
on essaie de faire
j'avais des histoires en moi que je
savais pas où j'allais et j'ai quand
même un crime car est arrivé lige comme
c'est là que ça vaut citron le fait que
j'ai commencé juste en racontant des
histoires et tu vois le numéro d'un
fidèle que dans mon show c't'histoire le
mahb et beaucoup puis j'ai fait j'ai
envie de vraiment bien la raconter
citons la fac dans ma tête je trouvais
ça cool de points la veille de la fin de
la raconter autrement dans la beauté en
prenant mon temps de voir vraiment que
pis moi ça me fait me poser des
questions de fait si tu mal ci dessus on
a besoin de ça me fait me poser plus de
question que je laisse un peu après sur
le public électeurs s'est posé chez eux
j'ai pas pour lui et moi je te parle de
ce site wassat amène à se poser ces
questions-là en quelques pages un peu
jeune et assez bien parler ses factures
mais oui
je me suis pas un bon montant dans la
vie donc je me mets beaucoup en scène
est évidemment amener via un moment dans
le show ou amman et à force de travail
et un jeune homme byrd détenteur je te
parlais de l'anecdote la première fois
j'étais chaud mais si je l'avais écrit
le lendemain que ça m'est arrivé j'ai
répété à joe goddard mais vu que j'ai la
distance les cheveux un peu extrapolable
exagéré mais la base est tout le temps
vrai dans le livre me tonti j'ai une
copine qui était neuf ans à mais jamais
arrivé de ma vie cette filière
représente vraiment deux blondes que
j'ai eu dans ma vie mais surtout heureux
mélange des deux personnages fait que le
livre c'est vraiment plus dans la zone
grise c'est beaucoup basé sur des vraies
fina vie j'ai perdu mon permis pour vrai
dans ma vie mais ça c'est pas passer
d'un bonheur que ça se passe dans le
livre c'est gégé poignée juste roddick
est mieux pour des concerts que j'ai
perdu été accueilli comme c'est lorsque
j'utilise vraiment d'aider des vrais
trucs que des fois je mélange des
affaires qui deviennent l'histoire puis
le livre qui est espèce si c'est que
j'avais peur je m'en allais
j'avais quelques histoires que je clame
ok ça marche puis là j'ai eu de la
difficulté que la temporalité puis dans
ma tête il est exact et puis ç'a
vraiment été un échec pour moi dans
l'écriture par monnet je voulais
abandonner
j'ai failli et qu'on va écrire autre
chose parce que j'étais à bout depuis
mai et titré son petit nid ont été
tellement fine qu'en fait non se
tiennent cois faut juste que ce soit
plus clair voici p puis à un homme et
moment je lisais des livres de joël du
caire qui est beaucoup dans la
temporalité aussi comme tout le temps
comme trois thèmes la petite et twitter
permet éléments même temps tu finis par
comprendre plus tu continues fait que ça
votre vaccin mais comme un peu rassuré
mais mais c'est là où à la fin je savais
pas ce qui allait se passer
puis c'est là que j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment grisant d'écrire c'est que
j'écrivais puisque jamais de ce style
d'écriture là c'est que vu que j'avais
pour marraine du projet comme fait juste
d'écrire la pièce au tc quoique je vois
des justes décrire comment je me sens
qu'est ce que je bois quelques hommages
tablier de quoi salanquais sas ampleman
et web est un personnage et débarque
je savais pas qu'elle a débarqué c'est
ce que je sais et speed la famille d'ali
puis jeu et c'est l'autre où il a fallu
je laisse aller si j'ai mis beaucoup de
pression moi dans ma tête sur la fin par
les cheveux permanisés c'est juste
puisque ray puisque c'est fait mais ça a
été une expérience qui était vraiment
space puis je sais que j'ai envie de
réécrire mais j'estime que j'ai besoin
de deadline pour écrit donc si j'ai eu
le sentiment un projet j'ai eu un
sentiment mettons que j'avais pas le
temps de le faire mais je pense que peu
importe quand elle joue a écrit un livre
ça va toujours je vois toujours avoir ce
sentiment l'yonne et de mes profs à
l'université qui dit quand tu écris
l'histoire et la fois juste que tu as
découvre way et lui parle de son
expérience il dit on et j'écrivais plus
un personnage qui rentre dans un train
le jld avait aucune des os qui s'en
aller puis pendant qu'ils étaient en
train mais je parle de son personnage
principal je pense que j'étais en train
j'ai découvert que le personnage il
manque une jambe fait qu' il dit
pourquoi pourquoi il manque une jambe
les cantines à écrire puis c'est un coq
et à la guerre mais perdu une jambe ma
guerre puis tout seul savait pas avant
de s'asseoir commence à écrire puis ça
m'habite encore un petit peu que le cac
avait dit ça parce que je trouve que
c'est c'est une belle façon de voir la
chose si tu sais pas évidemment tu peux
créer avec un plan mais c'était pas au
moins poreux à ce que le plan change
tu fermes les portes quand même à la
créativité qui vient je trouve mais je
pense que ça dépend des personnalités
aussi c'est je pense ça dépend du monde
il y en a qui ont besoin d'avoir un
peuple c'est vraiment la manière
optimale qui vont créer je pense que
c'est là où il faut que tu découvres un
peu de ta créativité doit baisser comme
trouver les bons moments au toi tu es
bon pour écrire c'est c'est un mélange
de plein d'affaires qui font en sorte
que tu te rendre ton projet optimale ou
le meilleur que toi tu es capable de
faire puis moi ni mon ça a été si aussi
un peu de voir plein d'amis que c'est
comme ça il faut vraiment qu'ils
écrivent physiquement et moi j'ai quand
même ça me tue
vous n'êtes pas capables pas drôle comme
sortie puis de réaliser à terme aux
fonctions harper à mi chemin entre les
cultures et les propos vraiment aller
trouver mon essence moi j'ai besoin
d'être en action pour vraiment livré le
bes
je pense qu'à l'écriture moi c'est un
heureux mélange dames et ma foi cela
j'ai réalisé faut que je sois faut que
je sache un peu je m'en fous j'ai
beaucoup de temps d'incubation
quand on dit que l'idée a pris forme
l'idée un peu tincu baba sylla finalise
mon moment d'incubation est super
important le moment où ge a pu sembler
des pires pense inconsciemment mais je
pense que ça dépend des personnalités
etc mais en effet que si tu laisse la
porte ouverte si je pense est l'auteur
de breaking bad qui étaient ils savaient
pas ce qu'ils sont là l'été puis laisser
tout le temps peur parce qu'ils étaient
jamais sûr si elle avoir une autre
saison qui fait pas aller trop loin
puis ça fait quelque chose de sa part
une chute à varna ça fait quelque chose
de tellement brillante et enfin que je
pense que s'il est aussi faux que
t'écoutes fausse h foot fou que ça me
faut savoir ou arrêter sa série en fait
5 saisons maintenant a été le sache et à
ses factures mais chez moi je suis
vraiment d'accord je pense juste que tu
trouves comment toi tu creed c'est
bizarre ce conte ce principe leur
décrire avec la réaction immédiate du
public
mais eux c'était lui écrivait pour la
série de six mais je pense sur god game
of thrones ouais georges martin que lui
au début a pas commencé pour une série
l'aï reste de livres
écrire parce que l'us tincques extra
justement ont peut-être parler de deux
façons de l'ue travaille extrêmement
qu'un plan de son tableau de travail et
un mur au complet rempli de post it ou à
son histoire s'en veut mais ça c'était
son mur était là avant que commence le
1er romain le il en reste deux sur une
série de huit ou neuf je n'aurais pas
puis il ya la réaction du public
ouais féclaz en temps réel pendant
qu'ils tentent règne de klose et sa saga
le public réagit à ces personnages fait
que le public veut le voeu que tel et
elles finissent ensemble veut que telle
ne meurt pas aime tellement tel tech le
lui sera mots ça c'est sûr ça modifie sa
perception c'est sûr que ça modifie
qu'est ce que lui à l'écrit si la série
avait jamais été achetés il aurait fini
sa sont aussi romain selon sa propre
idée que c'était fait initialement aux
selon son esprit créatures à tort mais
c'est sûr que ça modifie en fait le
parallèle avec aude et et ne l'ont été
la réaction du public en temps réel tout
aux trois semaines d'avancé la réaction
du public en temps réel c'est à modifier
des décisions tout le temps c'est
complètement compris tu sais que ce qui
s'en vient mais c'est juste un peu à
plus petite échelle le travail de gamme
en fait que gaby qui le type de prod
ados d'été c'est fou quand même que la
réaction du public puisse modifier ton
oeuvre tout ce temps coule de phénomène
c'est sûr que quand tu es dedans c'est
moins fun écarté d'un piteux pas accès
j'aimais city mais mettons des gens qui
crient comme youtube en game of thrones
succès avant de fauter marie forget pour
ça mais je comprends pas comment
quelqu'un peut créer quelque chose comme
ça blake est gigantesque
seul white comme surhumain dans ma tête
c'est comme gigantesque c'est vraiment
vraiment rien n'a pas tellement d'autres
apparitions depuis été harry potter mais
je sais c'est plus enfantin un peu au
départ mais j'ai rentré dans cette
catégorie depuis dix ans les larges mais
inventer un univers
c'est star wars est sa politique amène
ça n'a aucun bon cinq ans de travail que
j'aurais aimé qu'ils effacent dans
d'harry potter parce qu'effectivement il
ya tout ce potentiel la killer tiller le
potentiel du monde au complet porte un
petit peu ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire avec elle et les nouveaux ferries
bête s'est glissé puis c'est un petit
peu sont en train de fermer
c'est que tellement de potentiel pour
exploiter le boxster s histoire de
personnages alors que game of thrones
temps en temps parler tu entends les
légendes quant à ces affaires là ça
revient tout le temps tu t'entends
lointaines telles personnes faisaient la
file tels tournois et me son épée en feu
puis ses légendaires du stock de la
légende pied dans les botteurs titre que
des petits inondations comme le gac ou
partie gryffondor le jeu n'en avaient
pas c'est quoi son nom de sauf que telle
80 ans qui a amené c'était un magicien
les gens leur herti
mais on dirait que j'ai je suis passé
peut-être les filles qu'à un mois 15
france au complet genre je veux savoir
c'est quoi qui est aimée dans sa vie
c'est quoi c'est sa vie juste la vitre
d'un bol d'or si je pense hélas qui sans
voir un peu tranquille en plastique but
mais s'est scellée par un il ya
tellement de ce tacle à damas est fou
justement elle
il a fallu qu'à y penser seigneur des
anneaux c'est 10 pouces il est carrément
créer des langues des nouvelles langues
pour les fds dont on pourrait parler
cette langue là sur la prenait saint leu
des grilles travail je suis non inhumain
c'est inhumain comme ce gars là il n'ya
jamais chill et de sa ville comme les
stations son oeuvre de sa vie mais je
sais pas à quel point l'histoire est
vrai que commente tous à commencer
comment c'est en nous allons commencer
il était dans un un bord c'est
l'histoire que j'ai entendu dans un bar
puis un mépris napkin les par la cantine
amis puis à dire j'ai envie d'écrire
publié il ya écrit dans un trou vivait
bit soit sa nature ça c'était le début
de john van ou alors un chèque il y
avait une volonté de créer une
mythologie à l'angleterre qui trouvait
cannelle qui n'avait pas vraiment été à
la mythologie grecque ou romaine ou
scandinaves vidic ou dont il nous manque
un espèce de baxter ou huile légendaire
sifakis moi je veux créer silopi
maintenant la boue les hobbits
c'est comme les gens savent même pas que
c'est lui qui a inventé sur les gens
pensent que c'est juste comme un gobelin
ou un r oui ben on exposer les faits
comme les faits au but mais s'essayer
talkin to check lui il y avait il y
avait des étudiants en mythologie
scandinave aucune parce qu'elles
utilisaient les données cesser les orks
et de la mythologie scandinave mais mais
voit ça se sait que lorsque c'est ça
mais c'est ça que ça fait ça là même
influencé beaucoup beaucoup de choses
cdlf maintenant il y en a partout jeu
vidéo c'est vrai comme une crise
historique
c'en est un hôte aussi que la mythologie
spare parts large et ouais tout les
personnages que tu voies sûres telles
planètes et ils ont une histoire où ce
qu'ils pensent souvent c'est de la
fiction
par exemple c'est que beaucoup d'auteurs
qui participent c'est pô juste un gars
qui te crées c'est comme les geeks
ouais on a mis des les cadres des deux
stars wars puis fait qu'elles vont
effectuer leur écrire éventuellement en
fait on se repose on se posait la
question quels sont tes contacts de
proximité avec patrick senécal non non
je dirais pas bon job même institut non
non mais c'est un gars qui est très
qui est très au point patrick senécal
est vraiment vraiment accessible il est
super à chaque fois que tu entendes
entrevue tu dis c'est impossible puisque
le kx c'est ça c'est impossible que ce
soit lui qui ait cueille
il travaille très très relax moi aussi
quand j'ai su qu'ils allaient faire
partie du regroupement d'auteurs dont
ces données 3 avec simon mais j'ai des
patriciens cas je les lui là pour rien
qu'un peu vraiment beaucoup fait un
grand bond est vraiment vraiment pays
team
alice a résonné fort dans ma vie au
point comme ça a résonné fort plusieurs
livres qui fait que je commençais à me
fait triper fort fait que quand je suis
un peu je tais toi ça vraiment
intimidant d'écrire mes premiers mots à
côté des six mais maintenant je vois ça
vraiment encore une fois ma vie me
fascine c'est chaud sexy s'écouler crise
a chance à porte de sa peau on s'y sent
comme si tu m'avais dit on 3
le doute qui te fait triper le plus de
mon père m'a emmené genre en plus lui
vaut sa beauté qui volent rtcomm bien lu
mon livre il ya lu mon livre y fait ses
devoirs le lit vraiment vraiment gentil
car on s'y met encore un peu pour
montpellier comme a maintenu sa marche
c'est faux c'est plus léger il ya
beaucoup de dialogue
il ya vraiment vraiment pu me poser des
questions de prix le temps de les mémos
fait que chaque session mais j'ai envie
de récré en fait que ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai vraiment aimé de s'exposer c'est
d'avoir un document word relaxe même si
c'était pas relax dans le contexte mais
le type d'écriture était plus relatif au
moins c'est le sport peut aussi j'ai
comme j'ai mon stand up en avant
j'écrivais beaucoup pour urbania logique
où j'écris presque plus le
malheureusement je prends moins de temps
mais c'est comme au stand-up c'était
vraiment à qui on y va d'un gag open
spirit urbania c'était plus vraiment moi
d'aider réflexion des états dans nos
enfants demande est vraiment un genre de
mini journal intime et cheveux déguisé
puis
livre c'était vraiment de prendre le
temps de raconter des histoires qui fait
que j'ai mais si cette espèce
d'équilibré d'écriture d'envoi un type
d'écriture où c'est vraiment moi qui
parle directement un lecteur a passé
c'est moi qui met en scène ma vie puis à
pas si c'est moi qui raconte ma vie fait
d'armes était cité comme un peu un
espèce d'équilibré que je trouve fun
puis c'est le foie aussi de se rappeler
moi j'ai amené gelé comme écrire
beaucoup sur que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
auxquels je me suis dit d anecdotique
mais j'ai comme ouvert un document dans
mon ordi où je raconte des trucs des
fois que je vis juste pour moi puis
comme je ne sais pas ça va devenir un
livre je sais pas ce que ça va devenir
mais sur seul fan ça me calme sur seul
phone à extérioriser aussi facteurs
convergent secoue notre batterie ce
montant vient non pas de quête
je peux je peux demander alesi triste
vous garantirez la pâte
surtout comme un juste la plupat bon
retour de goss suis tellement de légende
ouais mais il vraiment avant qu'on a
fait est le salon du livre de québec a
semble t il redémarrera d y est superbe
on est vraiment vraiment talentueux puis
c'est ça c'est que quand il ya
constamment un livre sur lui
il ya beaucoup de tissus aussi je trouve
ce que tu dis est pas bon justin rien
faire c'est mener faut que tu en
consomme faut que tu il faut que ça tu
habites faut que tu y penses tout
travail puis ça des fois le travail pas
besoin d difficile c'est pour moi que
consommer de l'humour c'est pottow
thébaux - frank herrmann essayé il ya
aussi puis moi c'est là où des x fois
plus tard russie le syndrome de
l'imposteur le mot débutait ce qui me
stressait c'était un choix un autre
appui du monde que dre tôt tant pis si
ça marche c'est super si je commets un
geste opportunité leur jeu peut-il vivre
puis je peux être comme je le vis puis
j'y vais et puis je plonge puis je fais
de mon mieux puis s'attache pas d'ici
tant mieux ça glisse ça ne l'a pas grave
y'a pleins d'autres tellement brillant
qui existent voisine ses factures mais
je ne peux m'empêcher d'essayer de quoi
sert un nouveau sport
et il ya une histoire le monde mes profs
au cégep qui était assistant sur le
plateau de catch me if you can quand ils
sont venus filmer à québec
ouais c'est une séquence qui filmaient à
québec ouais et celui édité assistant de
squeeze d'enfants y amenait les les
cafés ont partout de jean piat pendant
ce n'est pas jean-pierre et je n'en
avais pas de quoi son nom qui disaient
ils disaient entre les tec dans sa
roulotte et écouter les films risquent
aussi distingué en déficit il dit ils
disent être des fois d'y écouter deux
films de 2 juillet cote et le guerrier
sur le plateau en train de tourner qui
il fait il fait piller pas comme ça joue
pas pendant qu'ils tenteraient de faire
autre chose il est assis devant puis il
ya eu une écoute attentivement les films
puis ça paraît oui vous apparaît parce
que y'a pas personne à l'âge que lui au
qui peut être aussi à jour n'ont cessé
de wall street le léguer joue big bang
bang et les gens qui se tirent au fossat
c'est fascinant je trouve que de voir
des êtres humains constamment se garder
on puisse se réinventer curieux c'est
une grande curieuse refusé sa part ex
intelligence parce que ces phoques top
que quelqu'un de 60 ans résonne aussi
fort dans nos vies à isaac parce que lui
il se sentit nous soumettrons pas très
bien que vidéo qu'il a acheté à acheter
un
cinéma dernièrement pour pouvoir montrer
les films qu'ils voulaient parce que il
peut le faire il a acheté le mondial et
continuez vous êtes à perte pour créer
il faut connaître qui qui sort s'il
quittait des choses qui est emmagasinée
que sont rentrés fin qui fait rentrer
aussi surtout au niveau de la forme
principalement mais au niveau des
connaissances comme tu nous donnes rogen
là une des raisons
quand c'est le podcast c'est parce qu'on
se marre des ceintures ring on se
parlait de ses podcasts puis une des
affaires qui fait que joe rogan et john
logan sait qui a pas peur de changer
d'opinion nom exact il ya papa
premièrement invite du monde avec qui
est pas d'accord - souvent comme chez
que l'on taille
il ya eu une opinion mais je le sais
maintenant parce que je suis plus
impliqué dans ce home une opinion
négative pour les vegan puis
dernièrement il ya invité richie et qui
probablement le podcast heures un dépôt
de personnes les plus connus qui est un
régal billon une conversation
extrêmement enrichissante des deux côtés
christophe joe rogan des intéressés mais
c'est ce qu'est la grande puissance je
trouve qu'il ya ceux qui y avaient déjà
avec n'est pas d'accord mais il peine à
jugements n'ont jamais jamais vrai dans
la compétition les wings activié curieux
il mais ils y assument complètement qui
est vraiment pas d'accord mais pourquoi
un pis c'est une grande force chez lui
et mon fils est justement un gauche
trouve qui est plus qu'une affaire et
qui seule permet qui assume complètement
le gac animé furent facture un temps par
l'ess le podcast de jerada way que total
et où est ce qu'ils savaient jouer un
rôle dans ta décision complètement parce
que puis moi à ce moment-là le j'ai
beaucoup écouté jo login enchères en
quête d'une réponse et l'émission a dans
notre donné littéralement donné une
l'émission avec marine sur le poker à
mort kim a réussi à tromper ses lois de
phoques broadcast marine qui considérait
quand même comme un intellectuel un gain
partie avec des petits démons qui
travaillent sur lui fait qu'il put et
plus psychologue dans son approche et
qui challenger rogen vraiment vraiment
fort voir que tu fais du parti de toni m
de fokine sur factor deux jours puis
sortent stand up qui est qui
qu'est ce que la la la la la société tu
peux pas faire un peu plus tôt était
jusqu'à doute je ferai ce que je veux
c'est être plus qu'une affaire d'envié
pis pour lui c'était deux trucs
complètement différent et c'en était
assez fait que me titille anime les
délits et commentateurs ici il fait du
gros stand-up et le pack à cela plus
hectos monde fume du widi s'entraînera
ma foi comme ya plein d'enfants cela
mais il veut juste vraiment je trouve
tous très bon être humain je trop il est
très ouvert à l'autre puis quand tu te
dis c'est vrai puis c'est quelle belle
qualité raid est capable de changer son
fusil d'épaulé
vraiment c'est tellement une belle
qualité avoir de d'avouer ses tares et
de faire comme crime tu m'as convaincu
c'est à raison c'est pas facile dans
quelqu'un tu as raison enfin que je
trouve vraiment vraiment cool j ouer
puis ces podcasts sont ultra intéressant
par la diversité des invités c'est parce
qu'il ya des lieux des buts et il
pourrait inviter tout le temps des
invités comme il l'a fait avec jean
jacques fils de métal qu est ce que ça
c'est sûr ça fait un pas de casque sauf
que ce procès qui fait non c'est bien
vite du monde qui est intéressé à avoir
une discussion où il vise l'une des
firmes et pas d'abeilles pendant six ans
par les deux sont surpassés écolo il
fait juste parler du fait que une
culture d'abeilles on peut changer de
sujet de ces places non non ça intéresse
la mort les adhérents concerne pas les
autres
grosse force de john logan puis c'est le
fun les podcasts justement tu es pour
des conversations comme comme on a
maintenant où est-ce que c'est pas fermé
dans la forme puis on peut on peut
élaborer sur prêts à faire et puis c'est
vraiment cool que ben juste le le succès
qu'ont eue avec le premier épisode qui
t'a église en ado ou est-ce que le monde
se sont claqués 225 ou est ce qu'on
prend une personne de culture populaire
qui utilisant depuis qu'on lui parle
puis cas nous livre des affaires que
paddy ne le pense parce que tout le
monde sont intéressés à si on en parlait
l'autre on dit maintenant la jeunesse
c'est souvent elle le stand n excluons
les snapshots faire le même nom ça
prouve le contrôle de ce 6e avec le
monde peuvent s'asseoir et écouter des
conversations deux heures et demie puis
est intéressé mais en fait je pense que
c'est beaucoup en réaction au parlement
je pense je connais rien mais chaque
année mais choqués on est souvent un peu
en retard sur un groupe de trucs qui
situés au québec surtout dans d'un pc
pas que négatif le 11 mai sur mettons la
forme justement les télés les vidéos
petits enfants depuis de faire je trouve
que c'est ce qui est dur en télévision
puis je comprends parce que mettons mais
s'est laissé laisser les publicitaires
qui m'offre mon salaire fait qu'il ya en
terrasse de ville c'est lui qui choisit
ses missions plus je suppose mais c'est
eux qui choisissent fois condamné cette
fois aussi si c'est qu'ils font ici
d'être un peu c'est que je trouve qu'on
est la télé c'est très formaté si tu ne
peux pas les l'on peut citer c'est trop
long la limpide mots tu vois les
entrevues je veux tout savoir et exposés
et télévisée puis ils voulaient
descendre à 22 minutes puisque même si
c'est beau la vision vers l'essence ces
points nous avons un nom mais ça va être
un best-of cette démarche ainsi quoi je
comprends complètement et pramac a
raison que ce sera meilleur
je veux un peu les dents de thèmes aussi
pour qu'on ait accès je veux titi quand
on parlait aussi d'un special commençait
pas la même chose écoutant les choses en
l'air mais je veux qu'on se rapproche le
plus possible de l'expérience des dents
sales de 20
personne ne communique t fac souvent je
pense que peut-être qu'inconsciemment
les gens aussi des fois c'est comme si
sûr qu'à force de donner du crav de
nuire à quelqu'un si je suis droit par
un tartare mais il va pas tripes et
c'est normal tout y est habitué à voir
fait que donner des avis et sa manie
monde sait que c'est un peu la même
chose je trouve que je pense de promo
sans réaction justement de faire mais
oui c'est vrai qu'on voit et messieurs
les ming puis les affaires quick mais je
pense que des fois mon nez ça fait du
bien aussi le sentiment pas le même
quand tu es lecteurs podcast complet un
sentiment qui est quand même le fun
c'est de faire tu prends le temps
d'écouter du monde josé puis ça fait du
bien
et des fois on dirait que quand tu vois
une information rapide
peu importe le degré d'intelligence de
l'information sur soi des fois ça
résonne pente en toi parce que tu te pas
l'occasion de faire le processus soit
jusqu'à cette information la facture
soit l'information puis hop ça tout de
suite
mais c'est calme on s'envoie tandis que
dans un podcast
admettons tu peux te rendre au point où
est ce que le mime et par exemple en
termes de réflexion api de cheminement
intellectuel mais tu fais le chemin fait
que tu te ra le pis ça ça tu habites
plus longtemps j'ai l'émotion tu peux
apprécier à voir ce qui reste dans toi
la discussion la conversation puis
toutes les personnes que des organes en
compte
john joseph qui est le site full y était
et est invité à un chanteur de deux buts
au cours des années 80 qui se relayent à
petit des gueules dans sa vie fait de la
prison ces puits pilote auquel j'ai
accès à une histoire qui est vrai est
racontée par la personne qu'il a vécu
puis ça s'arrête là on paie les golden
aujourd'hui heavy guen qui fait des
ultramarathons complètement 180° effet
des redmen free c'est drôle il parle il
parle du mouvement vigueur depuis dix
ans je suis pas vigueur mais pas des
tags
il explique bien pourquoi pas ouais
c'est super cool mais non c'est une
super belle formule pied
merci d'être ici c'est les gars on va
partir au podcast shopi il ya quand même
une marge en le dit qu'il fallait
continuer de faire ce que je vous
souhaite vraiment vraiment de juste
continuer le faire puis vous rendre
exactement vous voulez vous des projets
qu'on étire offert ce qu'on l'aurait
mais faites-le on a fait ce qu'on
s'accorde à le festival de musique qu'on
voulait faire on voulait avoir une telle
icône mais c'est sûr que tu es avec avec
rodez puis les contacts que j'ai tué
jeudi à vendredi je serai pas dit m a
aidé j'ai mon podcast ips a fait que
l'on peut avoir des invités qui sont
intéressants qui sont connus puis on
donne au moins une base pour partir mais
oui puis je pense que je pense que c'est
un beau projet avec ses visions que
telle
merci les gars vraiment d'invitation
puis bon succès avoue puis embrassent
jesse pour ben oui maison